Okay, Lyken released this tweet.
>> This is not a >> All right, so Lykan and I believe
this is the exact brand with the same like stopwatch type of
remote and everything.
if Assan didn't use stock colors, his hired dog trainer did and
you link me an XQC clip.
Okay, we'll check out the liking clip in just two seconds. What
is this? Is this going to be awful awful
>> You know Ka
>> That's his dog trainer.
>> Bro, what does he get trained to do? >> Everything's
not fully
shot.
>> He'll get he'll get trained to like basically be off.
>> This is an apology to a chatter name. >> Okay.
So, the the trainer says get a shot colored. It'll change your
life.
Hey, listen. We go where the evidence leads us. I'm going to
need this lacy and the trainer as well. >> JST kitten.
I told you about daddy's shot collar in confidence. Bad.
>> Uh, okay. Well, thank you for that with the Dr. Phil
voice for the five. Appreciate it.
Appreciate it. Okay. So, maybe he's trying to build up Ka's resistance
to electricity. Well, listen. We're going to go over this Liykan
VOD. Lyken took a different approach than everybody else. Okay.
Lyken's approach was very different. It was to say, "Hey, I've
got that color. That color doesn't do what you think it does."
So, let's let's just take a look. Let's see what it says. This
video will shock you. >> Shot collar. This is an e-collar.
>> Oh, hold on. Better start. >> This is not a shot
caller. This is an e-collar. And it's an important distinction
because people think of these as shot callers. And the concept
you have in your mind is understandably upsetting. old shock
collars were uh maybe one or two settings, both of which were
way too high and the voltage could be uh
>> what's the crying act for the prediction? What are you
talking about? I don't know what you're
what
I have no idea what
>> huge swings in voltage depending on the battery, the
wiring, the make, whatever. Um and they were overall not good
tools.
This is just a form of communication and these new versions can
be
adjusted very very incrementally and all you're trying to do
is get to a point where your dog feels something. So you've given
a verbal command and they're not listening. You've given a hand
gesture. >> So this is like the exact thing that Lykan
has or sorry this I believe this the almost the exact thing that
they're saying Hassan has >> and they're not listening.
You've used your body language and they're not listening. Oh,
predict. Oh, hold on. >> Hey, bud. Come on.
>> That's it. >> I didn't do a prediction. >> Now,
why might a dog yelp when you use one of these? If I come up
and pinch you when you're sitting there and not expecting it,
you're going to go. I don't even need to pinch you. Just >> Where's
the green light? Well, this one has a green light here. >> Poke
on the side. What the [__]
Same thing with this. They're not expecting it. Oof.
But it doesn't hurt. It's just a surprise. I'd almost say shock,
but you guys are being ridiculous about that.
That's it.
Elton, when he first started,
this was his correction level. It didn't make him freak. It didn't
make him shake his head. And this was his I'm noticing it level.
That's a five. So, correction only took a little more. The the
difference between those two, by the way, barely noticeable,
but that was
dog reactivity. If I had to go up to a
still not reacting like, "Oh god, stop, stop, stop, stop." No,
he because he's in that reactive mode, is like feeling it like
this.
Right after a dog reactive situation, we go walk into the hallway
and he reacts to random [__] in the hallway that
he hasn't seen before. So, he sees a garbage can and at a seven,
which is nothing, nothing whatsoever,
jumped into the air and screamed. Why? because he didn't expect
it in that moment. That's it. These are >> But by the way,
that's exactly what I said that like even if it was a rumble
or some sort of like uh like ultrasonic thing that you couldn't
pick up with human ears, even if it was that I don't like the
dog isn't yelping because it's in pain. That's maybe the most
brain damage take I've seen out of all of this. That like it's
so hard it's hitting the dog so hard that the dog's like yelping
in pain. That's that's totally mindful. Okay, anybody the people
like Techone saying that like, okay, these people are just losers.
>> A great tool. Uh maybe one day I'll do a longer video.
I'm not a dog trainer, but I've been working with the trainer
uh and using these every day for several months now. And they
have been a godsend. All it is is a tool to help you communicate
with your dog. And in doing so, in using this, um, it we have
become way more attuned to the the smaller nuances of our dog's
behavior. Um, this isn't some one-stop shop. Don't go out and
buy one of these and think you can just and tell your dog, "Hey,
no, stop. That's not it. There >> why you got to have the
Kai animation like you saw?" Well, it's got a little surprise
in it. Okay. >> There is a method.
>> I don't know, man. I just let the dog move. I don't
see why not. You know, the dog moves around a lot. Hassan, okay,
well, we'll get to it today. The dog does move around on the
stream, right? The dog does move around and Hassan doesn't freak
out. Uh, he gives a little context on this, but basically what
he says is he was stressed because his I think his internet had
died, his stream had died. He got it back up and he was like
kind of in a stressed m like a stressful feeling and he was just
like, "Ka, please just get back on your bed. Like, don't do your
whole thing where you [__] around right now. It's
not I'm not feeling in a cute mood now. Is that good? Probably
not.
But that that's, you know, once we get into it, that's what he's
going to say. >> Methodology to these, but these finishes
like and the dog yelping, neither of those things are inherently
bad. And if anyone has had a dog before, you know, when your
dog yelps, uh, I've had dogs that yelp because you picked them
up and they didn't want to be picked up. I'm not suddenly babying
them. I didn't pick them up a way that hurts them. Uh, that is
their way of communicating like, "Ah, what the [__]
are you doing? I want to lay here. That's it. >> This was
Well, we still don't know. Okay, we will go through all of the
stuff. We still don't know exactly what happened. I'm trying
to reserve judgment because I had to look through I looked through
some of this stuff earlier today. I've been tweeting a little
bit about it. So, I'm trying to reserve judgment though until
we've looked at all of the facts, okay? On the stream. We'll
go through we'll go through it together. We're gonna do it together.
Okay. We're gonna make it happen.
Okay. So, that's that's interesting that Lykan had one of these
callers just like posted like Yeah. It's not even a big deal.
So again, I would say,
man, I go back and forth. I would feel bad if Han used even the
the collar at all to get the dog to go back cuz the dog was already
going back. Okay,
the dog was already going back. The dog listens pretty well.
Dog's pretty well trained. Okay,
from here,
I think we're going to go right into the Hassanbot. Okay.
All right. So, Hassan went live today
and he
Oh, we'll have to go We'll have to go find this VOD as well at
some point.
He went live and he immediately addresses the Kaya stuff like
right off the bat on the stream. Okay. Okay.
>> And MB's are having a fantastic one because California
from Wake. I did not. And then here's nephew and uncle and dad
watching a
>> Yes. Uh I will be addressing that as well. Don't worry.
Uh
>> he's going to address it right away. >> Imminently.
As a matter of fact, >> imminently. He says >> there
is um there is a lot of Why are people mad about you, Ka? What
were you doing? There's a clip out.
>> God, it's all such slop. I hate everything and everyone
who covered it. I why do you feel the need to go to a chat and
express this Krantos?
I just I don't know why you like if you don't like something
there
>> huge catalog of internet
word players dogmstic violence.
>> Okay. All right. Thank you. Yeah. You don't you literally
don't have to watch any of it.
You don't have to watch if you don't like it. You don't have
to watch it, man. We're just checking it out >> there that
uh in the aftermath of me getting uh my internet. >> It
do be slopp. Yes, it do be slopp. That is true. >> I come
back live. >> What's up, division five player? and I'm
very frustrated.
And while I'm tweaking around,
I give Kai the place command as I usually do. And there's literally
a emote for it in the chat for place,
which is uh one of the things that she knows is she's like professionally
trained. And I think while she was like getting up and down from
the bed,
she I don't know exactly what happened, but I suspect that she
tweaked her uh the her do nail, like the upper nail that's like
on the side of the on the side of the >> For anybody who
doesn't know, the declaw is usually like further up the leg.
You have a little like finger claw up the leg from a dog. So,
they've got like the four fingers and the pad down on the paw.
And then they have their like thumb is like this thing that's
further up on their arms.
Okay. I don't know. It's not a thumb, but you get it. There's
like a claw little claw up there a little bit. >> People
speculated that I was actually shocking her do claw.
People were like, "Oh, you're shocking her." Then I suspect that
a bunch of people who have never trained a dog, never had a dog
that required training, being completely idiotic. Yeah. I mean,
it's a it's a it's a it is basically a a
storm because obviously I have a lot of haters. Obviously, a
lot of people love dogs, myself included.
Uh the clip looks horrible. Um and uh people were like speculating
because I was like moving around and they're like, "Oh, he was
like uh hitting a hit. >> How did the dog hurt its thumb
but not the four other nails?" Okay, so I'm not I can't I'm illustrating
but I don't have a camera. So it's up the arm more and basically
at this height on the bed is about where that claw would be.
So that's one of the things that people thought might have happened
is is she might have caught it on the side of the bed here hitting
a button on his desk. It is what it is.
They say you never take her outside too. No, the the worst part
about it is that a lot of people
the the most insane part about it is that a lot of people were
just like automatically under the assumption that I have uh I've
been like abusing abusing my dog.
People did assume that he's abusing his dog, which I find a little
bit silly. Okay, that's a dclaw right there. So, it could be
a little higher up. People were just thinking she might have
actually stepped in the bed, caught it on the bed somehow, and
that's what she yelled at. Okay, that's one of the one of the
theories people were running with pretty early on. And he says
that's what I that's what he thinks happened, too. He's continuing
to say like he didn't do something so he doesn't know what happened
but he assumes it's like something like that
I love more than most human beings
you know
what was going down too um
that's that's dicey I don't remember for sure
I'm trying to think of like when exactly it was
cuz the the thing about the VOD I what really needs to happen
is you need to have the VOD synced back to like >> stop
to have the audio synced on the VOD cuz his his audio's got this
like slight desync that makes everything weird. Let me uh let
me pull it up real quick. We'll look one more time really really
>> Pull up yesterday.
Here we go. It's like 3 minutes in.
>> All of America's much more consequential
violence. Right here she goes to walk >> It's the same
reason as to why America Ka please just
go.
>> So people thought either there on the side of the thing
or possibly
>> just stop.
>> She pulls the right paw up and it's you dude you just
don't know >> I don't know >> violence.
Okay. It's the same reason as to why America Kaia please just
>> going up. Well, hold on. The audio is delayed. So, look
at his face when he >> Go. Just stop.
>> Oh, the audio is not what the audio is not even anymore.
>> Okay. It's the same reason as >> Oh, the audio
was like desincted horribly yesterday. >> Why America Ka
please just
>> Maybe it's because he was live. The audio is desynced
by like a like I don't know a quarter of a second or something
yesterday. But
>> but she's yelping here, right? So it's I guess it's
this one, the left paw that they think she she caught something.
She did something here like left paw here. >> You stop.
>> I I don't know, man. I don't know, man. Okay, everyone
watching this like the zupruder film is sending me. Yeah, it's
fun. I'm sorry cuz I don't think Hassan hates his dog. So to
me, this is like low stakes, okay? I just don't think he I don't
think he hates his dog, so it's just very low stakes to me. I
think it's fun to just go and analyze, hyper analyze things like
this, okay? That's how you should look at it.
That's how you should look at it every
All right, we continue. >> Sometimes it literally looks
like she got caught and it hurt. You literally gave her belly
rubs right after. I know.
Um, it did it did get uh heavily heavily blasted in the orbit
and a lot of people are like losing their minds over it.
It's okay. It is what it is. They were saying Jen Walsh was going
to reveal it to us, but you shut her up.
No, she was she was uh saying that the collar is >> the
lady who >> too tight. >> The too tight collar thing.
Yeah, >> the collar that she has on is too tight. And I
was trying to tell her that like the reason why the collar is
too tight is because she has too much neck meat
and that's it.
Maya did not corroborate yet. So that must be true that you're
the worst. I know
she's been secretly
as an animal conservationist. She's been secretly actually participating
in the abuse of once again one of the most beloved
dogs on the planet. Here's March in the chat. Funny part is Kai
legit lives a better life than most people I know.
I know
it is.
like
to me already,
I feel like I'm going to lean towards believing Hassan because
I've seen like a lot of evidence that he cares a lot about the
dog. I I I have like whenever I've watched and a lot of like
the arguments around this I think you can understand. So, he
basically says a little bit, we're coming up to it, but we had
uh who was it here? I think trip to pound town.
Trip to pound town was asking uh what was he looking at, reaching
for? Why did he lie? Why did he not check on her? So many things
led to he shocked her. So, what did he lie about? Um and then
we don't know what he was reaching for. I can't I don't know
if he gives us an excuse for what he was reaching for. Why did
he not check on her? I think he says again, he basically says
that's my bad. I was being like I was being a a diva as well
and so many things lead I don't understand how any of those things
lead to the dog was shocked except maybe looking off to the >> It
is pretty nutty that that is like an angle of attack >> go
over later. Okay. >> Yes. Mike Vic is not going to be the
next guest that I have. >> What's up CIL?
>> I saw it all over my ex for every 15 posts I saw saying
you shocked her. There wasn't even one in your defense and those
horrific posts had millions of views. It's okay.
It is what it is. This is literally one of the
>> um I mean I have I have >> I'll say hold on. This
is an interesting I don't know if anybody has really listened
to this, reacted to it. I haven't seen any reactions to this
yet, but it's interesting to me that Hassan's usual play when
he feels like he's getting lied about is to come and like get
really angry and like lie about stuff and now he's just like,
"No, it's okay. I understand people being upset about my dog."
That's like a slight
people who are who have made it their full-time jobs to like
professionally hate on everything that I do.
This is an inevitable byproduct of this. It'll blow by in like
a couple days.
But as far as Hassan getting upset for Target hate when that's
his job is hilarious. See, this is the this is the meta. Like
people I just Okay, I I will say as far as I don't have like
a a ton of criticism for like haters hate watching, okay? because
realistically I do that a lot like right I even if I'm not hateful
of a person I can hate watch them okay so I don't have like a
ton of criticism for that but I just want to point out that whenever
whenever Dan Saltman says well I don't care about Hassan I only
care about Twitch and like the ecosystem they're creating never
ever ever ever accept that as an answer from him that guy hates
Hassan that guy wants to destroy Hassan that is his primary motive
is to destroy Hassan okay which you know okay it's fine but I
just I sometimes he goes well I don't even care about Hassan
Actually, Hassan's like a symptom of the N. Come on, man. >> Don't
think that I'm like directing targeted hate at others and now
I'm getting
my comeuppins.
Um, in any case, in any case,
it is what it is. I I do think that there are people out there
who saw the clip and were like, "This looks so bad." it and and
they got uh completely
they got completely duped by the framing of it and it's all right.
I understand for those of you who are confused by it. Uh I do
not have a shock collar for Kaya as I said yesterday, but it
doesn't matter. People don't give a [__] and all
of the uh other So we're not sure. Hold on. Orange Kush, we're
going to get there. Looking into he eventually pulls the caller
off and all of this. He says right here, I don't have a shot
caller for Ka. I'm not sure.
I even with all of the evidence and I I only I started streaming
about 30 minutes ago, right? 45 minutes ago. So, I've looked
at most of the evidence up to that point. There is evidence on
both sides for whether or not this is a shock capable caller.
I think I lean towards it being a shock capable caller, right?
we'll we'll keep looking into it. Okay, we'll keep looking.
All of the other clips that people uh have been showing
are either the Air Tag
or the vibration collar that she has, which I use when she's
free roaming. You didn't refute the claims until now. No, I have
I have I did immediately.
I did.
>> I did say Hold on. I did say yesterday though that
if he doesn't show that collar like on stream with Ka still in
frame, he's going to be in trouble cuz like nobody will ever
believe him that he didn't switch the collars out, go buy a new
one, right? Or do like do something. And and today we get a lot
more controversy with it seeming that way. Now, would he have
ever convinced a certain subset of people? Probably not. But
I do think there there might be some people in the middle. Although
increasingly the Hassan subject is becoming about as polarized
as actual American politics, okay, where it's like, is there
even a group in the middle anymore to appeal to or is there just
like two sides of the like totally Hassan in every possible way
or we will defend anything Hassan does in any any possible way?
It's it's quickly approaching the same thing.
Yes, this is true. Unlike American politics, it doesn't actually
matter. That's what makes it fun. >> My dog is a vibration
collar like that because a shot collar wouldn't stop the
>> Yeah. And the vibration collar for uh off leash training
doesn't work in the way that you guys think it does. >> Monarch
Ash
is training his starter to be able to take on Pikachu, but it'll
take more than that to beat my buddy.
>> Okay. Thank you very much for the five. Monarch Ash
Ketchum building up lightning resistance. Very intelligent move.
No, but you don't have to refute. People will talk regardless.
Yeah. In any case, her hair is far too thick as this chatter
also correctly pointed out for there to to work and for there
to be any sort of collar that actually works in that. Now, I
don't think that's true that the hair is too thick. The hair
helps, but I would say probably to me it's like her hide. like
she is a Tibetan mastiff by majority I think and like a Tibetan
mastiff that's going to have like one of the thickest hides a
dog will have like its skin is going to be so thick that like
getting a getting like a shot collar probably just doesn't I
don't know like you could get something but a a stock shot color
I don't think is going to do very much in any case
yeah I don't think the dog like that's mostly just to go and
say like I don't think the dog's abused even if this was even
if He does have like a shot collar. I just really doubt the dogs
abuse in any way >> in that way.
Asmin said police should use lethal force. Why is Swoo letting
him say that kind of stuff? I don't know. Cuz he's Asmin Gold
and he gets to say whatever he wants.
>> Well, if everybody's going to react to me, I'll get
one Asmin Gold crazy comment in here, right? Uh I was watching
this with Cherry or Luci pointed this out to me that like like
Huzzan, you know, expert framing here, expert expert technique.
He's like, "Ah, everybody's going to come react." I'll guess
I'll I'll throw a little Asmin little Asmin quote out there for
everybody to, you know, take away from
>> But seems like seems like Asmin saying insane things
on Twitch. Guess Twitch just lets him get away with it. >> And
this is like this is
one of the um one of the most insane
sagas that I have participated in so far.
You have to be aware that your haters shipped the clip like 30
minutes later happened on stream. I know it is what it is,
but I had a dream that Elon got you banned over this. Yeah, >> dude.
These are like, oh, we're seeing every layer of like terminally
online all at the same time. I had a dream that Elon got you
banned for this. Cool. That's uh
that you need to find a little bit just somebody else to watch
for a little bit. Not Hassan's not bad. Okay. But you should
find someone else to watch for a little bit before you are totally
overtaken. is laughable because once again I have been around
so many other content creators, people that do like literally
animal welfare advocacy and things of that nature. Um, this dog
is a famous dog
>> and she is one of the best taken care of dogs of all
time. Like straight up lives a better existence than I do. Lives
a better existence than many of you do.
Definitely lives a better life than my haters do. That's for
sure. As someone who almost always agrees with you on stuff,
the clip where you mentioned buying a shot collar, >> by
the way, none of that means anything. Okay. None of that really
means anything at all. >> The other clip where you talk
about Frenchies and your response to the collar being too tight
are all disappointing, but yeah, I'm sorry. Everyone is just
accusing you of something so awful. Yeah, the clips that they're
using are from this is a famous dog, therefore I couldn't do
something bad. Is it's it rings the same way that the Drake thing
like Drake's famous. He couldn't possibly, you know, try to groom
young girls now. 10 years ago when I was talking about not using
a shot
That's what I mean.
That's what's so crazy about it because like in the clip that
they're using from like literally 10 years ago when I had a different
dog,
my former dog that passed away, I'm straight up in the OG clip
being like, "Someone suggested I get a bark collar because Fish
actually barks quite a bit. Fish is my previous dog."
this is the clip that was not manipulated and I think they like
clipped it in a way where >> wanted to use a shot
>> here. This is what >> wanted to use. >> There's
a bunch of clips that are going around right now. Oh, trust me.
All of the tweets about this
all have like so many dude and I I can tell that like my follower
list is so cooked on social like on Twitter now. It's so cooked
cuz like I'll get like no buy in on any tweet that's just about
politics generally, right? But I post like an anti-Hassan meme.
18,000 likes on this bad boy. 18 18,000 likes.
That's how cooked my follower list is. All right. They're like,
"Oh, anti- Hassan slop. Let's go."
That's how that's how easy it could be. Okay. If I just wanted
to buckle down and really hate on Hassan, that's how easy it
would be. All right.
But I don't. No, thank you. Anyway, we
And uh people are trying to build this
>> people are trying to build this narrative.
And here it is. Here's the here's the 19 second clip. I'm going
to show you what they're using currently. >> My old roommate
wanted to use a shot
>> Why does he have this slowed down?
>> wait, hold on. Is this going to be the real scandal?
Okay, I'm going to make a wild allegation before we even get
any further into this thing. Okay, I'm
I did he slow this clip down so his voice doesn't sound like
his old voice?
Is that what happened? Did somebody do sound manipulation on
this to make it sound different? >> Um, fish and his dogs.
I have it still. I bought it.
>> That's not what he sounded like at that >> Who?
What is that flash cut in between dogs? I have it still. I bought
it.
>> Maybe that's with his new mic. He doesn't have the He
doesn't have the Yeti anymore. Okay. >> Incredibly effective.
>> This is this wanted to use a
wanted to use a shot caller.
I didn't know Nicandra was in on this. I'd heard Nicandra was
in the Forbes article or something was getting
um fish and his >> actually hold on hold on hold on I I'll
be real I just talked through that whole like transition
let me uh let me get back onto this
is this is this just what hello >> I'm manipulated and
I think darker to build this narrative >> and here I want
to rewatch
clip I'm going to show you what >> I didn't catch this
part where somebody manipulated one of his old clips at all I
didn't catch any of his >> using currently My old roommate
wanted to use a shot collar
um fish and his dogs. I have it still. I bought it.
That's weird. Who? What is that flash cut in between >> dogs?
I have it still. I bought it. They are incredibly effective.
>> My old roommate wanted to use a
>> Here is the original clip. a shot collar
um fish and his dogs
um for fish and his dogs barking.
I couldn't do it. I have it still. I bought it. They are incredibly
effective. That's literally from like 2018 or some [__]
but I I couldn't do it. Damn. Why' they cut it like that?
Uh, you know,
a lot of that happening on the internet recently, isn't there?
>> Why don't you let her roam around the house? I'm not
hatewatcher.
>> It's like,
dude, at some point these people are going to like get Hassan.
This is like the Trump derangement syndrome tier of haters, right?
Where like Trump can actually be evil because of the fatigue
that's come about from people looking at how things get edited
and how he got presented over early on. like Trump can now be
evil because there's such a fatigue from people just trying to
like get him done in so early
right? Like this is I feel like it's going to be the same thing
where it's like I hope Hassan doesn't just decide to be evil
at some point cuz like with the haters he's got people just won't
believe it. They'll be like, "Oh, it's the same guys who are
always clipping Hassan, always doing this crazy stuff to Hassan.
Han's probably fine." >> I'm just curious. Okay, so let
me address a couple things uh really quickly. First and foremost,
I have done this I have addressed this a million times over.
And not only have I addressed this, but I've also shown
um I've also shown like um not only have I addressed this, but
I've also they're going to get him. A bunch of people were posting
his address on on Twitter last night. Jesus,
not cool. Um,
yeah. I
I wouldn't be shocked if that's like a thing. It's I don't think
people want him to get killed, but like I I guarantee people
like Techon are just like they they probably get that brought
up to them. They're like, "Eh, whatever. He did it to himself."
>> Uh, shown in videos like Ka's day-to-day experiences
and stuff like that.
Um,
she gets out. She has uh an incredibly active morning and not
only that, but she also has an incredibly a active afternoon.
She gets 2 hours of playtime every morning
um at the either the gym or at the park that I go to and then
as a big dog, as big dogs often times do, she passes the out
for extended periods of time throughout the day. As far as not
letting her roam in the room itself, there is a very specific
purpose for that. That is because, and this is something that
I've described over and over again, the reason why she's not
allowed to roam inside of this room
with the exception of like stretching or this one, this one I
don't know about as much. I do think there's something to be
said for like like I don't think there's anything wrong with
telling a dog to stay and the dog wants to stay so long as when
the dog is distressed like actually distressed and needs to go
to the bathroom or needs outside or is in pain you don't ignore
it right I don't think there's anything wrong with having the
the with having the dog disciplined so the dog will stay laying
there for like four or like four hours up to four hours or something
>> getting up getting down drinking water things like that
is because she likes to lay on the ground. When she lays on the
ground, that's terrible for her joints. Every single thing that
I do with this dog is either with a professional dog trainer
or with a vet.
Okay? Professional dog trainer or a vet. A lot of people don't
understand how serious this is to take care of your dog, how
important it is to make sure that you have like proper activity,
proper socializing, and to make sure that your dog gets out.
Make sure that your dog is actually active. And more importantly,
make sure that your dog has a
uh why do you need it to stay in one place? You don't need it
to stay in one place, but the dog's probably going to lay around
for a lot of the day anyway outside of its play times, right?
Like that's probably what it's going to do. It's just going to
chill a lot of the time.
And so having it lay down on the bed, maybe that's good for it.
Um, just having it trained to lay down in one spot, that's good.
Uh, I would say if the dog was ever distressed, if the dog needed
to go to the bathroom or anything like that and you he didn't
let it get up, that would be a problem. Regimented and very structured
life.
Especially when you have a very large dog. I have a very large
dog.
large dogs have a tendency to get hip dysplasia.
Okay, large dogs have a tendency to get hip dysplasia later on
in their lives and they have joint issues. She is 120 lbs. The
other reason why it's important that a large dog is very properly
trained is because a large dog can accidentally hurt someone.
If not properly trained, a large dog can be very consequential
for others. If she accidentally played with someone and nipped
at someone, that would be a massive issue. It's a little different
than like a chihuahua.
Okay. It's a little bit different than a chihuahua. I think that's
>> they can also hurt themselves as well. >> Uh,
not using your joints doesn't help your joints. I actually think
this is just wrong for large breeds of dogs that have their joints
wear out after like 5 years to get like hip displasia after 5
years. I think that's just not correct >> for humans. That
tends to not be or tends to be true. But that's not even because
the joint is uh getting better. It's because you can build muscle
around the joint to make it better. Oh,
that is part of the reason why I take this very very seriously
and have taken this very very seriously from the start.
And uh there was a lot of like weird comments there. Like I'll
bracket off the the criticisms into three different categories.
Okay. The number one, why would that not be the same for dogs?
Because I think dogs don't get uh dogs can't do rehab in the
same way. There's like a lot of differences with dogs. And I
think this this whole thing with the hip dysplasia. I don't know
that you I think that's like a surgical intervention you need.
I don't think you build muscle up to get around that. Is the
broadest majority of people who saw that clip and were like,
"Oh my god, this looks terrible. Like this guy is abusive or
whatever." Right? which is hilarious to say about someone like
myself, especially considering that, you know, I
I am very very careful
and very good with Kaya. Like I
I spend every waking moment with her. She is the love of my life.
She's the most important thing in my life. Okay? I love her more
than I love most human beings. The notion that I would be abusive
to her is obviously ridiculous, but >> I think I I believe
that it is. And not only that, but also virtually every single
person
said Oh, hold on. Hold on real quick. Just uh
hold on. Uh wait, let me go find the Duke Masterson tweet.
There's a there's a there's a relevant Masterson tweet that actually
needs that is perfect for this precise moment. Let me find it
really quickly. Okay, there's a relevant tweet here. Hold on.
Hold on.
Cuz Dick Mastersonson had a tweet that I don't think I think
it was a little extreme. It was like 5 10% too much. Okay. And
it was this
100% chance Hassan ripped that dog.
Okay. I don't know. I don't know why he came in with this one.
Okay. Nobody was going in that direction and then came in over
the top like I think that's a bit too much actually. I think
that's a bit too much. And then Hassan talks about how the dog's
the the love of his life >> that has been around us would
attest to that for the record. That's number one. So looking
at like a 20 second clip over an 8 hour time frame that is negatively
that is negatively framed in a way to make it seem as though
like I'm abusive or anything like that is,
you know, it it can reach a much larger audience and if people
are oblivious to
uh they will get
they will get duped by it and it is what it is. Okay. Number
two, the second type of people that took advantage of this was
the regular guys like the tones and the
underscroll trolls of the world. From what I understand, Ethan
himself is
>> uh was in some hot water for using a prong collar, which
by the way, ironically enough,
>> just calling him tone is like the funny thing is is
I think this this probably bothers Hassan. It's probably like
a 6 out of 10, 7 out of 10, but I know Hassan just dropping in
here is like a 12 out of 10 for Techone. And he is going to actually
like sob himself to sleep tonight because Assan called him on
stream. Like that's that's unfortunately like that's how fragile
Tech is. That's how easily Hassan can win over him. I don't know
why Teto participates in this arena at all. >> I had used
the prong collar in the past for Fish, my previous dog. So, I
think he was like using that as well to be like, "Oh, look. See,
Hassan's a pron collar." And it's like, "Yeah, I don't anymore."
And also,
you know, it's just I don't know how that has anything to do
with me. Like, your audience is yelling at you over that sort
of thing.
And then on top of that,
on top of that, there was like the third category of people who
are totally in the periphery. Why not instead of attacking your
enemies, why don't you actually try clearing up genuine concerns
people instead? I am
>> uh wait. Yeah, he actually he actually is. He's actually
addressing something in a not this is the best son's ever done.
You have to give him you have to grade him on a curve. Okay.
This is the best he's ever done and actually addressing the material
concerns of people instead of just the people who are like mocking
him or or against him in any given drama. Okay, this is like
the best he's ever done. All right, now we're gonna get to another
part here in just a little bit that gets a little concerning.
All right, I just want to read a couple chats here. Uh, Lelayline
lost wants to watch the Techone clip again. We're not going to
watch the Tetoone clip right now. Okay, maybe at some point in
the near future. And then glowing pair said, "Tectone's going
to have to find a scare tree to post behind for this followup."
Okay, you have no idea what you've awoken. >> I am doing
that. >> There's a darkness in bit by bit, piece by piece
through all of the common things that I heard. The idea that
like Hassan, you don't actually [__] let Ka roam
in the house. This is untrue. I do.
I don't let her lay on the ground and instead I make her lay
on her bed. The reason why I do that is because I don't want
her joints to be up. Okay? She's a big dog. Big dogs have issues
with their joints.
Okay? Big dogs have issues with their joints, especially if they
lay on the hardwood floor for an extended period of
Not only that, but also, as you can see here, Kaia gets a tremendous
amount of play in the mornings with her boyfriend and girlfriend.
>> And like, correct me if I'm wrong, I think I saw an
essentially post some like Kaia stuff outside every
every single day, right?
Am I am I wrong on this? like they he posts like his walks or
whatever with his dog like nearly every day. I I was told this,
but I don't I don't follow him. So, Matt NLT following it up
saying, "Yeah, true, true, true."
So, so it's not like the dog doesn't get exercise. Wait, hold
on. Wait, dude. Where's the parag guy? Where's the glowing parag
guy? Techone literally posted this two hours ago.
There's many There's many tees now.
This is This is
POV. You're a goat in India, okay? And you're about to have the
worst day of your life.
Oh boy. Oh boy.
Okay. I was going to I was just going to scroll. Somebody asked
like, "What's Tone done now?" Teone spent like the whole day
totally seething about Hassan. Like the entire day. Yeah. The
whole day was just him posting clips of Hassan calling he called
Hassan the fs slur. said like obviously he abuses his dogs.
Uh it starts what here? Uh
right here. Yeah.
Starts with these ones. Jesus.
He might have got Oh, no. This is the Essler. This is the Essler
one. Okay.
Yeah. So, he just he was posting the whole day about Hassan.
Hassan post. Hassan post. Hassan post. Hassan post. Streaming
Mount Rushmore apparently.
Hassan post. Hassan post. Milo retweeting. Oh, hold on. Oh, no,
he didn't retweet this. But I would say, you know, if you were
thinking Teeone wanted to get Hassan,
Milo, I think, is was offering I think I saw Milo was offering
Hassan's home address if you DM him,
right? Which is insane. Obviously, obviously nuts, obviously
crazy.
And to start retweeting him or to keep retweeting him is a little
weird. See here. Nux Taku says some stuff about what someone
in government reached out to him for and Nux gave it away. I
love Nu. He says,
"Oh boy."
# free kaya. He reposted this one. This kind of funny one. Techoner
Asminold did this. Twitch would permanently ban them and everybody
knows it. I don't think that's true. Asan broke the law on stream
again. Oh, he's got like California penal code animal abuse.
Okay. Crazy.
Uh, more chank hatred. Okay, so
Teone Tech was going hard on the these people. Okay. Oh, also
fun fact, a little later we might go over the Cinder stuff. If
you guys remember, we did a Vtuber drama where basically this
Vtuber was trying to monopolize their artist, was trying to make
sure their artist wasn't making stuff for other people. And there
was a whole drama where they did this whole document about how
they felt pressured and it was weird, right? I don't even I don't
100% remember my takes on it. I remember being on this person
who got cancelled. I remember being on their side. Like I don't
think they proved that she was abusive or like awful to people
and they posted a response. So I think we'll check it out eventually.
so it's just been Techone whining about Hassan consistently.
She gets two hours of unstructured
play time
and that is the reason why she just passes out.
You only go one VOD bag and Kaia roams the entire VOD Lamount.
I know but it doesn't matter, right? Because if you if you are
in here for an extended period of time, you already know this.
You already know that Kaia gets to run the show, do whatever
the she wants. Okay.
But the problem here is
we're not invested in like the the narrative is not being guided
by people who are uh interested in
having a a reasonable opinion on this.
See, this is what I said. Okay? And I I actually this is one
thing I wouldn't have looked at was I didn't look for any analysis
that people did on how long was the longest time Ka laid there
for and if Assan was making her stay there,
But like to me, I think if Hassan's dog was just laying there
for like six hours a day every single day without being able
and then it's trying to get up off the bed and he keeps telling
it to sit down. I think that would be like I think people would
point that out. People would realize that over time, right?
It's it's weird that it took this for anybody to like be concerned.
It makes me think that he's probably It makes me think he's probably
pretty good to the dog most of the time and that the dog is like
not being abused.
>> Okay. I've never seen a Malin with a dog tail before.
Does something happen? Yes.
uh he bit into his tail so much that they had to literally do
a medical intervention
when he was wearing a Halloween costume.
He had a lion's tail and a lion's mane and when he was a little
puppy, he basically chomped on it so much that they literally
had to clip it.
It's so sad.
Oh, Lyan said that if you look at the last six streams, Ka moves
around plenty and leaves for long periods all days except yesterday.
That's what I was going to say as well is I would be shocked
if he didn't have like basically if the dogs like getting restless,
she can just go out. It's just if you're going to be in the streaming
room, you have to stay on your bed. No, Kai's a girl. I'm I'm
positive Kai's a girl.
that's number one. Yeah, we're talking about this other dog right
here. >> She gets a tremendous amount of [__]
activity in the morning and that's the reason why she's mostly
passed out for the entire duration of the stream
and
on top of that at night in the afternoon she gets another hour
long walk. The reason why she gets another hourong walk is because
sometimes she gets bored and that's understandable. Other times
she runs up to the door when my mom comes in. But of course,
if you know uh if you are in here, if you're in here for uh an
extended duration,
you've already seen that.
Okay.
Crazy to me that you have given uh you have to give attention
to this matter. All your viewers should know better. No, it's
it's okay. It's understandable. Especially because >> hold
on. I I believe Milo
Milo actually got his post removed. This was the post. It actually
got removed. I can try to find a copy of it, but this was the
this was the URL for the tweet.
I'll throw it in the kick chat real quick. But this was this
was the tweet. It got removed for violating the rules, I guess.
Especially because this is like a big big deal.
I jokingly said dog fighting.
The clips don't show her trying to lay on the hardwood floor.
She just stepped off her pad. Please explain. No, that's what
I'm saying. That's that's she steps off the pad to go lay on
the hardwood floor. That's why I give her the place command.
The place command is done for multiple different reasons, but
for the most part, the reason why if you've ever trained a dog
professionally or anything like that, you know that the place
command is given. Often times, if your dog is like uh getting
excited or or you know, barking or things of that nature, it's
supposed to like ground them and calm them down because you're
giving them a command. Dogs respond to dogs respond to to order
and a rigid
>> like you know the way Andrew Tate or Myron Gaines talks
about how like women respond to a certain thing. That's like
actually true for dogs. Like if you have an animal you're training,
that is how you treat an animal you're training. Just think of
like how Myron says women will be happy. That's how a dog would
feel if you treated it that way. If you were like leading the
dog, if you if you had a regimented structure for the dog's life,
all of this. Okay.
>> Oh, hold on. Hold on. I also wanted to
I also wanted to show this was the tweet. You're reporting Hassan
[__] for animal cruelty and you need his home address.
DM or text me for it. How do you Dude, that's a wild tweet to
just get away with, right? That's crazy to me. I mean, it's deleted,
but I if he's not suspended or something, that's pretty insane.
No,
I think that's pretty insane.
Hold on. Evil Johnny Bravo says, "But why did he react on a hair
trigger to Ka stepping one foot off the bed for one second? Does
he know for sure she's not wanting to walk around or uh around
the house?" I don't think you can have it both ways. Uh he already
said he literally I mean he talks about it. He was literally
like stressed and he told Kai to go back without thinking about
it and then he realized later he was an [__] when
he went over and checked on the dog which is like okay
I I'm sorry the dog's on stream so many hours a day. I'm assuming
you're going to have a moment where you're not putting the dog's
prior you're not prioritizing the dog and its well-being at some
point if you stream 6 hours a day every day with the dog on stream
for at least you know 70% of that. >> In any case I don't
know the exact uh reason as to why she yelped.
She has done so in the past as well. I suspected it was because
she like either tripped or she got her uh do claw like the the
higher
thumb looking uh claw
clipped on the side,
but that's I suspect that that is the reason. I don't know, but
I I know that there is a lot of people there's a lot of people
that immediately were like, "Oh, this is this is what's going
on. I see I see exactly what happened. Uh he is like secretly
um secretly
uh like pressing a button that he has on his desk or something
like that. I have multiple I have >> Oh guys, we're starting
this from the beginning. Okay, if you if you're caught up all
the way, that's fine. But we're going to we're going to watch
this so everybody can catch up. We're going to move through it
as a stream. Try not to spoil. Okay, >> callers. I'm going
to address the collar thing in a second as well, but I have multiple
collars for Kaa and uh I put an air tag on them.
>> I put an air tag on all of her uh collars to make sure
that you know I know where she's at. And one of the collars that
people are pointing to in the uh from previous days or from like
months ago
is the collar that is a vibration collar. A collar that I use
specifically to
A collar that I use specifically to communicate with Kaa when
she's free roaming at the park or when she is, you know, uh,
off leash run. Either take that he has to make sure she doesn't
lay on the hard floor or she's allowed to wander the house unsupervised
in which case she will just lay it wherever and hurt her hips.
Uh, I think you could either be in the room or not. And if she's
going outside of the room, which she doesn't most of the time,
then I assume if she was doing that for a significant amount
of the time, they would find a solution,
right?
But I don't think she spends a significant portion of his stream
time outside of the stream running around. Okay? Because when
you when you leave your dog >> also free, >> his
parents are there, I believe, >> to go out on the trail
or whatever, >> there are going to be instances
where you can yell for her to come back to do recall, but because
she's so far away that she can't hear you. Okay, that's where
the vibration collar comes in.
It vibrates. It doesn't actually have any sort of like shocking
component.
Okay. And there are multiple different versions of this.
Um, there are the noar collars that I believe both vibrate and
also emit like a large sound, like a loud sound. There are shock
collars as well. They all look very similar to one another. Okay.
But the vibration, >> the funny thing is is I think he
I think it's entirely plausible that he doesn't have a shock
collar, that he doesn't use the shot collar leads or the pressure
collar leads or whatever the the actual stimulus is, right? I
think it's entirely possible, but I do think it seems likely
that it is
it seems likely that it could be one of the ones that has the
leads on it that would allow you to and maybe he modified it
or something. We're going to we're going to >> collar is
what what they were pointing to.
Okay. To be like, "Oh my god, he has a he has a collar that he's
using to abuse her and shocking her." >> There are a lot
of dogs who use this >> these people out for >> Okay.
There are also a lot of dogs
>> Uh if you're just going to try to go like spoiler, it's
this or that. Um just >> that use a shock collar as well.
Is the vibration collar a positive reinforcement technique? No.
But positive reinforcement techniques are necessary for any kind
of training.
Like there is no it's not I believe you could use a vibration
collar as right. You could use it as a positive reinforcement
thing. I assume you could use a vibration collar in the exact
same way that you could use a clicker to provide a stimulus that
is followed by a treat. So that they do the good behavior. You
give the stimulus that says they're going to get a treat. they
know to come to you to get a treat. I assume that would be everything
I know about dog training says that that would work perfectly.
>> It's neutral. This is by far your stupidest controversy
yet. I know. But it's a lot of people understandably love dogs.
I do think it's kind of crazy that one of the 10,000 times you'll
place on stream, the yelping only happened once. I know.
I know. It's such a >> We're gonna find out. We're gonna
look into it. >> It's such a uh common thing.
It's such a find it we're like going through this as a group
and I just find it very funny like just so you guys know the
vibe in the chat should be like oh we're going through this we're
walking through it and we're like interested in in going through
this piece by piece building up like exactly what we think about
it over time. But a lot of people are here like you have to believe
what I think. No, no, no. You have to believe what I think. No,
no, no. You have to believe you have to believe what I think.
Please believe what I think right now. And I'm just saying that
like I if that's if that's your vibe that that's what you want
to do. I'm sure there are a lot of other people on Twitch you
could just try to bully into thinking what you think. I'm just
not interested in it. If that's what you want to do, there's
a lot of places you could go. >> Common thing that I do
that there's an emote for it.
>> Can you explain docking to the new viewers, please?
What do you mean? >> Wait, what?
That's a reference to the Aiman Animations video.
>> Little Levity in the middle of all this. >> Dude,
none of these guys crying about it train their dogs. They know
nothing.
Shock collars are not bad for dogs if used correctly. Any dog
trainer will have you put the shock collar on your arm and feel
it. Yes, I have. I have done that.
It's not even a shock collar is not even like actual electrocution.
It's like a temp's machine.
Okay, that's the other thing that people are completely oblivious
to. Yes, a shot collar is like a Have you if you've ever used
a temp's machine?
It feels like
It's a TENS machine. That's what the That's what the sensation
feels like.
>> Sweatpants freedom. We're we're looking into it. Okay.
There's a couple points for there's a couple points against.
I
we we're going to look into it. Okay. >> But it doesn't
even matter
>> we do need to watch response for the sake of being fair.
>> Like I don't have that anyway. I think you should wear
the collar and bark for chat would make everybody happy including
us dgens. >> Very strange. Very strange
for training, especially for dominant breeds. Shaw collars are
not bad for dogs if used correctly. My friend used to use it
around his neck. I'm a vet assistant. It is meant to break them
out of a fixation if they're not responding to commands. And
yes, it does have to be tighter than a normal collar. No, the
reason why her collar is tight is like this is um this is kind
of what I I think this must be a little bit normal that shot
colors are like this type of shot color that Lyken demonstrates,
right? where you have like the the fine tooth like control over
it and make sure it's not like actually hurting the dog. I think
this is probably like a humane way to train a dog, right?
It seems fairly humane. Now, I will say Hassan can't really use
the Oh, well, I do I do this or I use this like in a humane way
cuz he's definitely said
it's he's definitely said he doesn't have a shock color. There's
no shock available from that color. Okay.
So, he's kind of he's kind of worked himself out of he could
have used that excuse. He could have said that, right? Because
she just has a lot of neck meat. That's it. That's the only reason.
There's no other reason why she's uh she has a tight collar.
From a psychological standpoint, a shot collar that vibrates
is that still considered a form of positive punishment, but it's
extremely minimal in terms of actual damage. Yeah, there is no
there's no real uh damage there at all. I think the worst aspect
of it was the the worst aspect of it was that I was
>> um I was frustrated because >> 9,000 just tipped
$5. >> Hold on. >> You'd be shocked to learn it was
indeed a shock caller bez.
Hey, thank you very much for the five. Easy educator 9,000. >> The
internet had cut out. >> And I didn't immediately like
rush to her. I went to her afterwards to see if she was all right,
but she was of course
and that's it. And I do take accountability for that. Like it's
up. I should have immediately went over when I saw her yelping
and that's it.
Like I >> Okay, so he's saying, "Yeah, it was a mistake
not to go over the second I heard her yelp. It was a mistake
not to go over. make sure she was okay.
>> But the idea that I'm like a abusive dog parent is completely
ridiculous.
um now that I've already addressed this, I'm sure
we will
uh I'm sure that uh
the rest of the stream will be normal as we get to the regular
uh regular broadcast.
You looked hella guilty afterwards. Yeah, brother. I'm
I'm currently
immensely jetlagged. Okay.
H I feel like I feel like it's got to be stressful. Okay. You're
like this size a creator and some drama. Dude, this has to be
stressful. Literally the entire internet. Like I feel like he
didn't
I I don't think the jet lag thing is a real excuse here a couple
days after he's come back. I think this is like bro like the
entire entirety of Twitter was calling you an abusive like a
dog abuser. That's [__] up, man. Also, they saw a
clip of you teaching her showing her in the pool and went there
drowning her. Yeah, but that's why I'm like I mean it's the same
as this. Like you see uh if you watched Ka playf fight with her
friends,
this Belgium Malininoa gets very aggressive, but they're just
playing. They're not like from for the
especially if you don't have a dog. And everyone's dog is different.
Listen, I sure hope Hassan didn't spend the whole night coming
up with a solution because
listen, he didn't come up with like a very good solution for
this. Okay,
>> you can look at it from afar
and think, "Oh my god,
this person is uh you know, this person is like engaging in a
dog fight or anything like that." >> Air Force One, if
you don't like the content, you don't have to be here, man. Love
you. You could go wherever you want. You don't have to be here.
>> I plan on doing a I plan on doing a a video on the different
uh collars that she has eventually
so that I can show you
maybe do like a like a dog trainer style video or like a day
in the life of Kaa
>> um video where I show you what she does every single
day
>> that I feel like there's no way to do that video and
not I don't know man and not like
do another thing
>> service Dog and behavioral dog train here. Vibration
collars are used as a cue to get the dog's attention back to
the command. Also to place command and laying in one spot for
long periods of time, are used to ground the dog, maintain structure,
and is even used with service dogs and other working dogs for
them to have a spot where they can be a dog. I agree with Assan
for protecting her joints. I know, but like it doesn't matter.
There there are people who like professionally trained dogs who
will look at that and be like, "No, this is like I don't know
exactly what happened here, but the place command is perfectly
normal." Okay, we we should be getting here. I think we're getting
right up to the part where he actually does go and show the caller.
>> Is this what you have to deal with on a regular dumb
controversies and desperate things to discredit you? Yes.
>> Just a fair warning, certain ex co-host is going to
do an entire episode about this with you and the thumbos. So,
just going to happen all day, King. I'm sorry. This is their
new meta. I know >> it is what it is. I think it's really
funny. I think it's really funny for uh a lot of people to
like uh assume that she's like uh
I'm a little worried now whenever you guys say >> what
is happening with [__] Twitter? Twitter is not working.
>> Whenever you guys >> Oh, is that her just no leash
walking?
>> Look, look at this.
>> Oh.
Oh my god. How is this possible,
>> bro? When you have discipline in your life, when you
have a rigid structure in your life,
when you work hard,
you can achieve anything. Okay.
What? Okay. That was uh I just thought it was funny. That's the
most red pill I've ever heard Hassan sound. Okay. That sounded
like some some actual Myron T or so Myron Gains and Tate. It's
true, but like it's it's just funny. [__]
>> Buddy would never do that. If Kevin was here, he would
have ran right in front of that van and got hit and died. >> Buddy
would have Buddy would have at a certain point loved to do that.
You just didn't teach Buddy that. >> We tried. >> Ga,
let's walk.
>> Oh my god, this is insane. Good girl. You know what?
There's some [__] >> I'm I'm
>> love that. Yeah, that is like the outcome of professional
dog training. He's like, when you have discipline in your life,
you could do anything. >> I don't know why this is like
not working.
Can you just show the collar? shut everyone up. XQ said he would
donate 50k to a shelter if he did. Okay. >> Oh, here it
is.
>> So, XQC said 50k to like an LA dog shelter. If Hassan
can show the collar,
>> doctober 7th, free hostage. Kaya. I can't even tell.
I can't even tell if people are like saying that in justest and
they're making memes about it or if there's like people who are
sincerely saying stuff like that because they're like, "You're
abusive to your dog." with a maid outfit, too.
Yeah, man. You explain things well and show the caller, though,
dude. >> Ka. Okay,
come here. >> This is one of uh Ka's many callers. Come
here. >> Okay, so he's pulling pulling the collar off.
Okay, here we go. Now, this this is all going to be Hassan doesn't
even realize that he just launched a thousand streams analyzing
this whole thing at the same time. Okay, there is a million different
breakdowns. I cut my own clips out of this. Okay, we're going
to watch. We'll just watch it first. He shows the caller off.
Okay, we'll watch it and then we'll start rolling it back. We'll
start analyzing a little bit. >> One that people are talking
about. Okay, >> is the one. >> This is >> That
was a Hold on. That was a good view I don't remember seeing before.
Give me a second. I might need a screenshot. >> This is
the one. >> We need his finger to come off here. Hold on.
right there where he like moves his finger forward.
>> I think that's a screenshot I need. I think that's it
right there. Okay.
>> No, that's the one I need. Okay. That's That's giving
us so much info right now.
That's the one we need right there. Okay. All right. We get a
good look at the back of this bad boy right here. All right.
As we move forward, that will be You'll see why it becomes important.
Okay. You'll see.
>> Okay. This is the one. This is the This is the one that
they saw.
>> It has the capacity to vibrate
>> and that's it.
>> Capacity to vibrate and that's it. Now, I think if I
had to put money on it, that seems to be a lie. But I we'll we'll
keep looking.
That's it.
Good. There's the Air Tag. There's the vibrator.
It also uses It also has a flashlight component to it at nighttime.
And it also has a tracker on it. When she gets lost, if she were
to actually get lost, you are able to
um it emits a sound.
Okay. Watch how he holds it. Okay. So, oh man, I don't even know.
I haven't thought about how to like actually present this to
people. There are a couple different theories. All right. There
are a couple different theories about how this is not the model
that this company provides. There's there's a company that provides
this
thing. Okay. Hold on. >> The donation go through.
>> Uh, okay. Well, thank you for the donation. Didn't read
it out for you there, but thank you. Thank you.
>> Somewhere Destiny's vibrating. >> Okay. Jesus
Christ. Gross. Thank you for the three. All right. Um,
so people are saying that this this company doesn't produce this
something that looks like this without the capacity to do shocks.
that's that's one side of this. And then there's another side
of it as well where basically if you look at the manual, you
can't really take the leads off. There are metal leads that exist
on the back of this thing that you can't take off and we should
be able to see evidence of. Okay,
so that's it there. I actually didn't watch beyond this point.
Is there much more after this? I feel like there can't be. Right.
Literally JTO said, "I don't know what you're trying to point
out, but thank you for your contribution, Amplifox. I'm sure
somebody somewhere is appreciating it."
There's more. Okay, we'll keep watching.
He gives the command one more time. Okay, so they walk away.
Comes back. >> Okay, Ka comes back.
>> Good girl.
place.
there are days where Gaia doesn't wear >> I love I love
that there are people who like don't have dogs that just like
look they'll like they'll start doing okay they're basically
like the green line guy from Twitter except for dog expressions
they'll be like look Ka looks depressed she looks so depressed
here she look doesn't the dog look she's so scared of being shocked
again she's so traumatized
>> there are days where she wears a different collar.
Okay,
this in and of itself
doesn't actually work in the way that you think it does. Okay,
>> this is the
flashlight.
>> Is the flashlight. All right, we see the green beeping
there. >> Okay,
and this is when it vibrates. >> Okay, what is he doing?
He just turned the flashlight on again. He's turning the flashlight
on again and again.
Is he going to Here we go.
I see nothing. I hear nothing.
It vibrates with like a little controller. Okay, we'll go over
the models in just a little bit.
>> Trust me, there's a there's a lot to there's a lot to
go over there. Okay, so he puts it back on. Puts the collar back
on. Does he place one more time?
>> Does he show the controller? No. But we have a good
idea of what the model >> place anyway. It doesn't matter.
Okay, I
>> Yeah, it's it's okay. We've got a whole bunch of things
here. Okay, so we're gonna go through it. >> I understand
why people are uh I understand why people are concerned about
it. It's okay. It makes sense why people would be like, "Oh my
god." Um this person is uh uh this person is being abusive if
they only saw that clip. It doesn't matter. And this will not
go away for the record. I'm sure that I'm sure that uh the people
that are saying that this is not like the real deal will continuously
>> Hold on. >> Caesar donated $3. Animals don't follow
unstable pack leaders. Only humans promote, follow, and praise
instability.
>> Thank you very much, Caesar Bel. >> Uh and and
uh and expertly scrutinize every minutia to say, "Oh, no, you
don't understand. this is,
you know, this is uh this is a situation where uh he's trying
to get out of it or anything like that.
Even an e-car that uses a low current isn't a shot collar. It's
no worse than a cell phone vibration if used correctly. Yes.
>> Yeah. Sure. >> Will all those that slandered you
apologize now? No. Because it doesn't matter. It does. >> Okay.
Okay. Okay. So, I think that's that's got to be close to the
end. Now,
of course,
some people felt invested enough in this to go and look up possible
models. All right. Now, I don't know the exact transmission of
but I know I know Dan had a hand in it, and that's whose Twitter
I'm going to use. So, this is uh this is somebody passed this
info on to LoaderBox. All right. Someone passed this on to Loaderbox,
and Loaderbox decided to go into it. So, this is what they think.
It's the mini educator. So, this is basically the exact one that
Lykan showed as well. if we remember right the exact one Lykan
the ET300 mini educator
half mile remote e-collar which does have shock prongs
it seems to match in shape >> it does
>> in the positioning of the charging port in the texture
of the plastic unlike
this one with the much more curvy light than the one the sun
has
this one which is vibrate only also
>> charging on the side. >> The one Assan has the
charging point in the middle. >> Much like the shocking
version where the prongs that could deliver the shock are simply
removable. You can just remove them or apparently
maybe plausibly ostensibly cover them with black tape.
That seems to be where we are now. Okay. Closely match.
yeah, I know that. Trust you. So Loader Box posts this stuff
or he's got this stuff. He's looking to this stuff. Uh we have
Neandros came back. All right. Friend of the stream. Neandros
came back and said, "No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no. That's not real. That's not the thing that happened here.
Give me a second. Let me go find this precise tweet
really quickly.
I think I've got two Nandro's tweets. All right. So, the thing
is >> easy. Hold on. I got to show the show I posted first.
Tip $5. Electrical tape does not come included with Mini Easy
Educator 300. Electrical tape does not come included with Mini
Easy Educator
>> Okay, I understand that. So, somebody on the H3 sub,
I believe, noticed that. Hey, it appears that we've just got
a piece of tape
pasted over. Okay, we've got just a piece of tape here covering
what could be leads or some underside of this
>> I think that's obviously true. Seems obviously true
that there is a
>> that there's a piece of just tipped $5 wannabe
shock collar 20-in blades on the
>> Thank you very much, Train. Appreciate
So yeah, somebody went and around with like the brightness here,
the contrast. Could pretty clearly see there's a piece of tape
on the back of this or something like tape, something covering
the back of it in general. All right. Now, the weird thing to
me is is there should be two metal leads that can't be unscrewed
from this. Right. So, while this could be true that that it's
black tape covering it, it should be obvious from some of the
angles. Okay. Thank you very much, BB Poison, for pointing that
out. I'm glad that you can imagine this for yourself. Good, good,
good. So, why not just buy another collar? Because this is the
better. This is like the best collar and it's reliable and it's
what everybody uses, right? It's like a pretty well-known brand
of collar and you get all the features of the vibrating one only
when you buy this one.
Like, you don't lose any features, right?
You can see one of the leads. Okay. Well, possibly you can see
one of the leads. Hold on. I don't know that I've seen the leads
here 100%. But I did go and cut out a video. All right, I did
go cut out a video so that we could try to take a look. I got
just this piece by itself. Hold on.
Soundless. We can look now. Where do we think we see a lead under
this piece of tape? So again, notice I think people are concerned
that you see a raised bump. Do you? Okay, hold on.
Where do we see the raised bump? Looking looking.
You think you see raised bumps where the leads would be here?
I feel like that piece of tape socalled is not
is not necessarily like a raised bump somewhere. The image in
the third comment and then you linked what? Look at this. I genuinely
think I have the answer. Well, you might. I mean, there's definitely
there's definitely an NARS thread that goes through a bunch of
this
Hold on. Look at the third comment.
The third comment is this one. Has Maya commented on this yet?
That one? This
What is this? Okay, what are we thinking? We're thinking this
is a lead and that's a lead or I don't know. I don't know about
this. I don't know that this is any more clear. Look at the video
of the prongs being removed. Uh, we will do that. Trust me, we
will do that. I know there are metal prongs that should be here,
right? That just shows the tape. I already have the tape.
There are no holes that you could cover. Okay, there are no holes
to be covered when you pull the leads off of this. There are
two metal pieces that do not get removed.
Oh well, evil Johnny Bravo, just link the comment, bro.
You just got to link the comment, dog.
Okay. Okay. It's this picture that you want me to pull up.
This picture you want me Okay, cool, cool, cool, cool. That is
just not working. Is it Reddit? Uh, your link is broken for some
reason. and send it to me on Discord or something, I guess. Unlucky.
link the comment that it's put in,
I think. Anyway, I'm going to pull up the Nandros thread now.
Where's my Nikandros
Right here. Okay, we're going to pull up this Nandros thread.
Take a look. All right, so
Nandro says it's not a shock color, it's a vibration color. The
green light, it's all there and it's clearly scratched up. So,
it's not something Hassan bought in the last 12 hours. If there
are removable shock prongs on this model, you can now recognize
the model and point out if it does or doesn't.
Um, okay, hold on. So, the collar model seems to be the ET 300
Mini Educator, which is an e-collar and contains optional contact
points for delivering an electrical stimulation, but the device
also flashes red when activated, which wasn't visible in the
original clip. Is this the Is this device capable of delivering
painful shocks anyway? It's almost certainly not right.
So, apparently it blinks red
uh when stimulation's applied. Interesting.
Jube says the shocker was on the other side of the dog. Well,
let's keep reading because I've been told this this NAR stud's
good stuff. There's also the PG300 which is a vibration only
collar. Which one is it? Uh, I think there's reason to believe
it's not this one, especially given the piece of tape on the
back. But, uh, manual, the ET300
depicts it having little metal prongs sticking out. Uh, little
metal prongs sticking out of it. Even when you remove the removable
prongs, but they're not visible in the device Hassan is holding,
it's flat on the back. So, I have not seen the prongs sticking
out of the back that anyone has shown me that like seems to be
like, yeah, just there. Oh, hold on. Let's go back in this. How
far back do we have to go to get to him pulling the collar off?
Right here.
I had this on a YouTube video before. I should do it again. In
any case,
uh I'll pull up my this guy right here. I just don't believe
that you actually see metal prongs on this anywhere.
>> Like it it looks like the metal prongs would have to
be there.
Uh yes, you can. I don't. So, show me an image where it's shown
that you can see them. You should be able to see the prongs,
man. Uh, it's not even these prongs, though. Okay, it's not these
prongs, but here, let's take a look at this. Okay, so these come
off and there are metal prongs on the other side of this that
should still be sticking out. No, the prong, these prongs cannot
be removed. Again, observe the decadros thread. This example,
when you pull this off, do you see these metal leads that cannot
be removed? These metal leads cannot be removed. These specific
metal leads cannot be removed. Okay, these bigger pieces can
be removed. Hold on. Apparently, we've got it in research. One
second.
This one. Let's take a look at this comet now.
This is charging point on the side. Oh, this is already a point
we looked at. This is something Loader Box mentioned already.
So,
this could be the what do you call it? The ET300. This could
be the ET300. It absolutely could be. That could be why the uh
the tape is there.
It could be,
but I I don't know that it proves that the dog was shocked either,
right? It could be the ET300.
And again, I think you would see the metal prongs here unless
he broke this and taped over it just to show on stream. Those
are two different I understand these are two different models.
This is the model they're saying he doesn't have. This is the
model they're saying he does have. I understand what I'm looking
at.
I see it.
I think the issue is is basically all of these models run off
of the same thing. And I don't know that we know that this is
like the model that you would get if you bought it today or bought
it when he bought it or what. Like they essentially all use the
same transceiver, right? They have the same transceiver for like
all of their models, I believe, or like a whole bunch of the
models. Why doesn't he just show the model number? He could do
that. People could demand he does
>> Would people believe it at this point? I don't think
so. >> Educator 9000 just tipped $5.
Easy Educator 900 can be easily distinguished from its sister
model via the lead indicators rounder bezel and red button as
opposed to black.
>> Uh, thank you for the donation again. Thank you. Thank
you for shilling your product on my stream. Okay. No, I don't
see. So, this is another one. And I can pull up the contrast
picture, but I don't think I see the prongs. So, I guess the
I don't see any evidence of the prongs here at all. And I'm not
sure there might is there No, there's another one of these that
evil dragon bravo linked earlier, but or it was in the thread
here.
I think the issue for me
is I don't see the the prongs sticking out anywhere. So, I think
you'd have to move on to he broke those off specifically. Where
is this? Not those ones. Hold on.
Where did this picture go?
This one. I literally can't even see what's going on here.
I literally can't see what's going on here. I don't know what
this is. Yeah, I understand that there's tape over this, but
you'd think that the way he's holding it, you'd think you would
see some indication
of
You think you'd see some indication of where the leads are, right?
That's edited. I don't I'm not going to say it's edited without
looking at it, but or without looking more closely at it, but
you just think you'd see the uh these smaller leads here. Okay,
look at the original stream quality footage. And I can kind of
see what looks like black tape. Did he genuinely file the contacts
down and just tape over it or is that some model that doesn't
come up with their website on their website? So, there is like
some kind of there is tape here. Yes.
But he would have like this would have been to break you would
have had to break those things off, right?
They're not very small. They're not very small. They would be
clearly visible. And the fact that he puts his finger in the
middle of this ever would would pack it down, right?
But he could just break down those leads. He could just break
those off, too. At which in which case, like, why does he just
get somebody to go buy him the the vibration only model?
I don't know why he wouldn't just go buy the other model during
the night or something. Oh, take a look. When the prongs are
removed, there are still metal prods sticking out. Did he have
them filed down? Yeah. So, he would have had to snap these off,
right? Oh, sure. That if you buy a new one, it it doesn't look
worn enough. Sure. Okay. So, I think we he would have to snap
these off and then tape over them. I do think I tend to think
that it's this model, right? I do think it's like capable of
shocking, which is why I said earlier it seems like there's a
lot of evidence that it could be capable of shocking, right?
That that's like the model that comes and you could shock somebody
with it. I don't know that he uses it for
because in this deep lying into lying about this uh I think he
could be easily he could totally understandably be this far in
that he would be lying right I don't think that's true
most yeah I know I know it's a lot about the dog colors okay
let me see if Nicandra posted some other stuff here got Nicandra
looking into this
why this is not a career ender uh cuz I think even if he did
it I don't think he's like abusing the dog to be honest. Oh yeah,
this is the same thing. Yeah, yeah, sure.
Nandra Nandros I think, listen, Nandras is Finnish. If I had
to guess Nandros's politics only knowing that he's Finnish, I'm
guessing he's like quite conservative. Okay, most Finnish people
I know. Quite conservative. More conservative than you'd expect.
All right, that's that's funny that he got a mic DM and he's
like, you know what? Nope. Nope. I'm not I'm not trying to help
you.
The only sides, the only side Nicandros is to is the side of
the truth. Okay. Oh, that's not the picture you posted, Evil
Johnny Bravo. Just to be clear,
so the point that they're making with this one is that it is
clearly this model, right? And not this model. That in in this
model with the vibration only model, the charge would have to
be here or here, the charger. But this is the charger that corresponds
with the middle point. You misunderstood the the picture you
posted.
See the lure box clip? Yeah, we covered
You are completely wrong. Okay.
Um, you understand that the picture is saying that the middle
charging point is here with the with the prong version, right?
Just to be clear, like the point the picture is making is that
this proves that it's the shocking version. I know this cuz it's
literally the picture that Lurbox had up on his stream came to
the same thing. Charging point middle side. Charging point middle
side. We have the I'll have the video somewhere. I've pulled
it up before. We can easily find just the manual video here.
Uh, what is this?
Uh, mini educator ET300
setup. Where is this guy? Wait, hold on. Hamilton dog training.
This
>> All right, guys. This is a video. I'm going to show
you how on one of these >> trap is really difficult to
make uh fine tune adjustment. >> So, he pulls these leads
off and there's these metal pieces underneath. Okay. So, you'd
have to file them down, snap them off, something along these
lines. >> And now, let's put on our upgraded contact points.
So, depending on if your dog has long
>> what's your verdict? Abuser or no? Uh, I mean, this
was probably not great,
but I do think like not abuser in any case. I don't think you're
an abuser automatically just because you have a moment where
you're like kind of frustrated with your dog. It's not like he
kicked his dog. It's not like he did anything that does like
lasting psychological damage,
>> Easy educator 9000 just $5. >> The Easy Educator
9000 is perfectly safe and ethical for the purposes of training
canines is completely harmless unless you're a bad doggo.
>> Okay, thank you very much. Easy educator
Um, people want me to pull up the the picture of him pulling
on fish's tail. There's a picture of him pulling on fish's tail.
You want to you want to send me that video of him pulling on
uh pulling on fish's tail, his old dog from like years ago.
If you want to link that, that's fine. I don't think he created
an audience that thinks it is Luawi. I don't think it's his audience
that's going after him. Wait, his audience loves him. His audience
his audience would like totally have no problem with this. They
never would have like held him accountable in this at all. What
are you talking about?
His It is skinny young NMP. It is.
I don't I don't think his audience would have like been bothered
by this. They would care about dog abuse, but they watch him
interact with the dog every day, right? They watch him post his
like videos going for a walk with the dog every day. His audience
doesn't think he's like mean to the dog.
So, you think if his audience shocked the dog, they would not
think so? If he shocked you think his audience I think you're
trying to say, would his audience not care if he just openly
shocked the dog? I don't know if they would think that it meant
he was an abuser. I think they would just think like, "Oh, that
was a moment,
right? He's going to seem human to them." Yeah, but internet
ray, I guarantee you everybody who watched Elinity with like
regularity, basically everyone would have been fine with it.
And it was everybody else who was mad at Elinity, right? And
just to be clear, Elinity probably didn't I don't think she hurt
anything like moving that cat, right? Like that cat was not hurt
with Elinity. I It's bad. It's a bad looking clip though. like
a really bad looking clip.
Has this been posted yet? Old video of Hassan doing something
with uh his dog. Let's see. Let's check this out. What is
>> Come here.
Stay. If you run right now, I'll you like I'll actually get you.
Okay. In front of everyone. Stay.
>> Stay. If you run right now, I'll [__]
>> Oh. Oh my god, the slow-mo. The slow-mo totally got
me here, guys. The slow-mo totally got me. Actually, that he
said, "I'll you in front of everybody." That's definitely the
kill you >> is the big one. Let's watch the pull. That's
probably not good that he pulled on the tail, right?
>> That's probably not good that he pulled on the tail.
That's a pit bull, right? Death threats are their love language.
That's kind of true. Stay. If you run right now, I'll you like
I'll actually kill you. Okay. In front of everyone. >> Oh,
was he Wait, was he stepping on the tail or something?
>> I don't see him stepping on the tail. >> Stay.
If you run right now, I'll [__]
>> I don't think he's I don't think he's stepping on the
tail there. >> Go a >> Yeah. Yeah. Can we find basically
before he pulled on the tail with the dog on stream and see like
if he's really angry at the dog and he's pulling on the tail
from that point of view?
Would you do this on stream? Um,
I don't know. I feel like pulling on the on the dog's like tail
is not good, right? Like I I feel like but not because I know
it is attached to their spine or something cuz like I just feel
like the dog turns and bites me if I do that. I feel like that's
Dude, can we acknowledge Can we acknowledge the
the sheer
courage of Hassan [__] grabbing a pitbull's tail
and pulling it backwards by the tail?
Like, how many fingers did he just risk doing this?
My god. My god.
That's a joke, by the way. Some people are going to take that
seriously. That's a joke. I think that's bad. probably I don't
take the oh I'm going to you thing seriously if anybody's trying
to like soy signal over that I mean okay
um but listen
I I've heard a lot of people talk about Hassan's interactions
with this dog
including people who hate Hassan
talk about destiny and they've all said he loved that dog he
took great care of that dog he loved that dog love that dog love
that dog so I I don't know And if the if this guy streaming 8
hours a day has like two bad interactions with per animal life
over the course of like 5 to 8 years like maybe I do you just
give them a pass on that cuz it's like oh we've all had a bad
moment with an animal before where it's like we probably do something
we shouldn't have done like not necessarily kicking them but
like yeah like pulling them back by a collar or something they
like
you know some like that. I feel like everybody's got that moment
with a dog.
And it's not because you abuse the dog. You love the dog. It's
because you have like you just have like a day at some point
and you're like really impatient with the dog and you do something
that you would never do in most cases, right?
I I feel like that's just is that not just part for the course?
Am I Am I speaking like a crazy language here?
No, it's not. Sometimes your wife gets
I'm telling you that there are things you could do. It's like
sometimes your wife comes you you come over work and you like
yell at your wife when she says something relatively mild and
you like were having a really bad day at work. That happens to
like literally everybody and it's not good but it obviously
and people are acting like it doesn't and it's just very very
sad that you're acting like it doesn't happen that you don't
understand what I'm saying. All we have to do is find the stream
here. Just find the stream of him walking fish here. Right. I
think that's all we got to do. We just go find this stream and
watch it in its full context
here. Uh, I'm going to effing you look for this. Somebody look
for this in Filmont. We'll just go watch the whole thing.
How's it not abusive to shock the dog because you don't want
it moving from the spot you want it to lay down. No danger involved
because he obviously keeps the dog in that spot without shocking
it 99.999%
of the time,
right?
Nobody's ever seen him shock that dog on stream. The dog has
never like jumped backwards as if it's like shocked and and like
reallyed up on stream. Uh it's very clear that he uses the place
command. The dog knows exactly to go walk over and lay down on
the bed. Right. That's what I kind of suspect. My doll Harris
is if there was a reason he could have had the shock leads on
possibly it would be the the thing where he's like, "Well, mom's
been too soft and she's like losing her discipline." And can
we say that that was abusive in that moment? I mean, you could
say it's abusive in that moment, but I don't know exactly like
how bad it hurt the dog. I don't think I don't think that shock
hurt the dog. I think the dog was shocked in a an emotional sense
as in it was surprised,
right? Whether by whether by it stepping on something or it getting
like um some stimulus from a collar, I'm not sure yet. But I
I think the idea is that he's abusing this dog. This is wild,
right? This is wild to me. The on trains Ka, you want me to look
at your meme? Okay, thank you. >> Uh you you want me to
look at your meme? Hold on. The dog yelped, though. Um, th this
is something you only say if you've never raised a dog, you've
never actually taken care of a dog, you have no experience with
dogs. Dogs yelp out of surprise all the time.
If you are unaware of that, you just don't have a lot of experience
with dogs, I don't know what else to tell
If you think that the yelp, if you've been convinced by anybody
on the internet that that yelp is indicative of that dog being
in tremendous pain or any pain at all, you have been brainwashed.
You are a [__] Yes, I get it. Uh, Emperor Palpatine.
Thank you, Tenstone. Thank you.
I didn't say Yelp for no reason. What did I say, Age? What did
I say? I said the dog was surprised by something. Whether that
is him using a collar, which is possible, or
by the dog like, you know, misplacing his foot or something.
I don't know. Han's POV of him forcing his dog slave to stay.
Dude, you guys are going to ruin what could be really funny memes.
And it's sad. Don't ruin what could be really funny memes for
everybody.
Assan's dog when he tries to escape Hassan's lefty talking points
for one
Okay. Like, it's funny, but just don't run it. Don't run it so
hard into the ground, okay?
It could be really funny. Just Dude, I'll say again, I can't
believe how cooked my algo is that like my my anti my possibly
like neutral posts get nothing. My anti-hassan posts 19,000 likes,
6.5k likes.
This one, uh, was it 10? Somebody linked me this and I just downloaded
and reposted it to Twitter. Somebody had this idea before I had
this idea. I said Raiden like he's going to be the new Raiden,
like Mike Pence, and somebody linked me the clip and I just reposted
it. So, uh,
>> when Hassan notices you inching your way off of your
doggy bed,
>> I don't think so. >> It's so good. It's awesome.
It was trending. Yeah, this one was trending. Yeah, this is a
good one.
This is Top Bronson creation. Okay, speaking of Top Bronson Creations.
Okay, I think we've got another meme here. Hold on. Top Bronson
shot me another meme that I should probably post as well. I I
asked him for it specifically. Okay, not going to be not going
to be great times for Hassan.
we can have this uh along the bottom of the stream. It's what
he set it up for.
All right. Don't be a shock jock,
Don't do it.
Okay. Where are we at with this? I don't know where we're at.
Oh, by the way, hi, Lykan. I don't know if I said hi. I saw you
post and then I I don't think I actually said hi. So, hi if you're
I liked your video. Okay,
let me just let me see where I am in this whole thing. Do I have
other stuff I want to do here? I don't know if I've got other
stuff I want to do with regards to this. Okay, some people linked
me some Listen, we've got
I think I had Hutch here. There's like the Hutch reaction and
the H3 reaction. Do we want to look through some of the H3 stuff
and just see how
just see how it looks?
React to Asmin. Oh, hold on. Is there Is it Wait, is there Asmin?
Is there good Asmin tent? Maybe there might be some good Asmin
gold stuff. The H3 is peak. Okay, we Well, we might have to look
at the H3 stuff, too. Listen,
I'm fine with like looking at people and and what they think
about this. It'll be pretty easy to tell if people are like totally
motivated to like try to with us on here or if they're, you know,
>> and this is something.
>> Okay, we got Asmin Gold already.
Okay. All right. So, all this does is breed >> Wait a second.
I got Now I got to move it down. I'm trying to move it in the
in the right position. >> Positive association with Israel.
So all this does is breed resentment
against Israel and also depending on how >> That's cute.
By the way, I hope you guys know that that's like a cute interaction.
Just if you aren't like human, if you only hate this guy and
that's like your primary way of gaining oxygen. That's like a
funny That's like a funny interaction of the dog like kind of
sneaking away after it's been given the place command and then
Han looks over and is like, I know, I know. I'll get back on
the bed. I know. [__] him
>> in the same positive association with Israel. So all
this does is resentment
>> against Israel and also depending on how
and uh Yeah. All right. Well uh let's see here if I find another
one of these. This is something else. Excuse [__]
>> Hold on. Asmin hears anti-Israel rhetoric and instantly
gets triggered. No, no, no. That's not true. Asigold. I think
Asigold actually hates Israel. Okay. Asold's just multiple different
kinds of racist at the same time. All right. He wants he wants
somebody to come along and get rid of the entire region. All
right.
Shut the [__] up.
Shut the up.
Nobody's mad. Let me turn the camera, guys. This is a proposal.
Hold on.
Nobody's mad.
No, Ben.
If he if he wears one
and Chad gets a punish when he gets one guide to unlock the stun
locker.
>> Hey God. >> XQC XQC also supporting. >> I'm
just saying >> I don't I don't make the rules here. >> The
same the same kind of DJ XQC supporting it.
>> And uh it's funny as [__] Yeah, I guess
so. Right. And uh and if you don't
>> Okay. I is there some point I don't necessarily want
to watch him rewatch every clip but if we could get through >> that's
a lot of money wow what wanted to have her but realize that she
is going to be too big for their daughter and the dude who had
her >> saying Asigold is the avengers of racism I'm just
saying Asigold does a lot okay he's got a lot of he wears a lot
of different hats just not tiny ones or towels okay >> originally
was like yeah she eats way too much already. And also on top
of that, like we already have some big dogs and I'm having a
child. >> Wait, why is XQC
welching on the bet? Hold on. XQC bet shelter. Let me Let me
Hold on. Let me see here.
50K. I'm trying to find the XQC bet
Where where is XQC's bet? Somebody find >> That's basically
it. So, where's the comments? Uh, here from the >> I'll
find it. Hold on. kick.com/xqc.
I'll go find the clip real quick. Let's see. Let's see.
Clips. Clips. Clips.
100k. Now, we got to go last day. Where is this bet? Where is
this bet? Where is this bet? So, Hassan, sorry. XQC said he bet
50K. He might have just done it on Twitter to be honest with
you. He said 50k
if Hassan shows the collar on stream. Hold on. Hold on. Looking
for it on his Twitter here. I don't see it on his Twitter either.
The [__]
He said he was going to donate to a shelter. Yes, he said he
was going to donate 50k to a shelter.
Put a clip in content links. Just give me a second. Roll over
there. Uh, wait. Is this the clip I'm asking for or is this something
else? This is like another fish one or Yeah, it's another fish
one. Okay,
cool. Uh, I'm looking for the XQC bet thing here cuz I could
have sworn XQC's bet was if Assan shows the color on stream,
I'll pay him. It's not here for >> Hold on now. Hold on
now. >> What is this?
What is this? >> What is
this? And this is like SC. It looks like some tape. This looks
like some tape on. >> What is he circling here? >> Tape
on that skitso. Guys, am I skitso? Like am I over the top? Look
at like this is taped over. If you look if you if you peel back.
>> Right.
It looks like two losing it >> that have been taped over
literally.
>> Yeah. He doesn't understand the the type of um collar
this is which is fine. >> Hold on now. >> You don't
necessarily you don't necessarily expect it from him.
>> Uh so Gringle linked us the pulling the tail clip again.
>> Come here everyone.
>> Hey the exact same stuff. >> Come here.
Oh, it's just the same clip multiple times in a row. Okay, cool.
It's It's the same clip we watched before.
Scroll up for the XQC clip. Uh, you can't scroll up for the XQC
clip. Scroll up in content links. Okay, hold on. Okay, where's
the bet?
Looking looking. I don't I don't see it. Could you just link
it again? Uh, I'm
I think I just got to move on. take it too long. Um, I can't
I can't see it there, Gringle. So, I don't know what's going
on.
Anyway, we uh we'll jump back. I think we're on Asmin Gold's
VOD here. >> Future trying to learn Kyore. That dog is
going to know more about American media than I will. Um
uh I guess so, right? And so, a lot there's not a lot of comments
from this either, but uh the recent stuff, but yeah, it's just
kind of nuts. Uh let's go back over. I'll see if I can find a
few more of these and uh if there's anything else. And uh this
is
Okay, hold on.
This was apparently the the bet clip.
See what it says here.
>> This is the flashlight. >> Whoa. Stop putting
your fingers on it, man. Christ. >> This is something else.
>> Jesus, man.
>> Okay. And this is when it vibrates.
What the what the what
I'm show I'm show
see I just bought it it's brand new you guys see it >> it's
right here come on bro come on bro it's not hard sell for like
two minutes like it's not why does he keep [__] >> cool
cool cool cool um that's a different clip
and then this is the bat one apparently he's going to pay the
>> back to me uh uh I found a apparently very reputable
no kill uh shelters and I'm donating to those >> kind of
shady. It might be um
it might be I tend to So my thoughts here are
my thought here is specifically that he has one of the ones that
you could have the leads on that you could shock something with
but
but that it like he doesn't have the leads in or he's actually
removed the leads entirely. >> Um I I'll already give you
guys the name of that one. He's g you three options. Uh I'll
deal with that later. I'll do it anyway. I don't give a [__]
I I I don't give it. He wants to lie. Whatever. I don't give
a [__] man. I said I just >> Well, I think
the issue is he showed it. He just might have showed that it
was like a shot caller. >> I'll do it anyway just because
it is what it is. >> What I find to be really funny about
this
is one of the big issues. >> So,
you look at God's tweet. Nope. Did not look at God's tweet.
Give me a second. Uh oh, that's not God. Why? Why is Twitter
like this?
This guy.
What's going on here? So, this is pretty funny though, not going
to lie.
But that is the picture right there. This is the what? The pager
only
The four screws there on the edge.
>> Stick it over them and you twist them to the left to
loosen them. >> There. Hold on.
Sorry to disappoint, but the vibration only collar doesn't look
at all like the image on the right and is in fact the exact same
as the one Han is holding. Same LED layout. Even has the missing
piece. Oh, hold on. The threaded bolts the prongs screw onto
can actually be removed or taped over.
So, I don't believe he taped over the prongs. He could have he
could have like broken them off, but I don't think he taped over
them. Right. As the missing
>> this is like a worthless video. This doesn't show Yeah,
this video doesn't show anything. Okay. All right.
I think he's he's taped over something back there. And dude,
I
this is uh this is rough.
All right.
I don't know. I think we
check out this asmin for a little bit and then I'll move on to
the H3 stuff. No, it's just fire. You You'd have to understand.
I I don't think it's possibly that one. I don't think so.
Based on what we've seen,
you guys get the video
or the image. There it is.
I cannot, Dude, I cannot imagine
it. Dude, is this what you got to do to get famous? You got to
pull up this meme and laugh at it and pretend this is funny.
I can't do I can't do it, man. I can't. I I'm sorry. I'm I can't
I'm
That's too much for me.
That's too much. >> Okay. I I think we're we're better
off now. And uh in a way, it's kind of your
>> It is kind of funny though. It's I don't I don't find
it super funny. >> It's really funny. >> There are
a lot of Trust me, I tweeted out a bunch of Hassan memes about
him shocking his dog, okay, without thinking he's abusive or
that he even shocked his dog. There's a lot of funny jokes there.
>> asold in the frame is a nice touch. Yeah, I guess so.
Right. Yeah. I don't know why I would do this. Exactly. I saw
as well. No reason to have shocked her unless he didn't want
her to move at all. And so this is what they think. Uh this is
the image right here. People think is uh you know because uh
with the wouldn't the tape be like jacked up? I think you can't
tell if the tape's beaten up or not or not on this one, right?
Like you could look at the tape here in the higher contrast image.
I don't think you could really tell.
Like it looks kind of like it's beaten up. I don't think it looks
new. It's got hair all over it. And so I think he probably has
the like transceiver that could have the shocks the the shock
prongs on it. I think that seems most likely to me. Unless he
wants to pull that off of that exact collar and show the model,
right? And show that it's like not that model. The two white
spots on the tape from being worn out. I think these are pieces
of fuzz, not not it being worn out. Yeah. I just I think it's
far more likely that it is the shock capable version of the collar.
>> Yeah. or I mean shock as we watched the Lykan the Lykan
uh video earlier seems like that collar is like fine and it it's
probably not hurting the dog
in general. I just I think I'm just falling back to the position.
I don't think Hassan abused the dog. I think there's reason to
believe he might have had something on the dog, right? But I
don't I just don't think that the dog yelped out of pain. And
I think if you think dogs only yelp out of pain, you just haven't
been around dogs very much. It's not fuzz impressions from the
indents underneath. Then why when he turns it to the side are
there those impressions not visible at all?
Major Dr. Gastley. So there are times where he turns it to the
side here and you can't see the impressions at all. They're very
slight. They're literally
Like you could tell there's tape there, but they're literally
non-existent. Like like the tape if if those prongs were there,
the tape would not cover those prongs. It would be very obvious
that those prongs
are like that the tape could get like pushed down. Yes, he has
to have removed the prongs. Sorry, I'm just saying people are
saying there's impressions that show the prongs are there. I
don't think that's possible. Uh, Amplifox, go ahead and send
me a screenshot of this.
I I I believe you, but send me a screenshot, okay? Because I
don't see it. I don't see it, man. I don't see it at all.
If the prongs are not there, does it shock? No, but he could
remove the prongs quite easily between the streams, right? So,
the prongs could be there
and
holes underneath are causing impressions. I'll I'll take I'll
take any of them. I'll I'll take any screenshot where you can
show me that good. So, he grounded them down. Well, that's possible
that he ground them down, right? Or just snapped them off with
pliers. You could easily snap You could snap the ends of off
with pliers like that, right?
You could have.
I wonder if it would keep functioning correctly if you did that.
Perhaps we need to fund raise to collect one of these actual
collars. Okay. And to see what's what exactly is going on with
them. All right. I think I don't know. I'm probably not going
to do too much more of the aspold stuff. I think I do want to
see some Ethan commentary on this though, right?
Or what could we do? We could also do
Hold on.
We could also go and look and see if we've got like commentary
from streamers
about what is this? Hutch looking at the >> Yeah, it's
definitely taped onto for >> I noticed this tape like immediately
when I first saw this
or I thought I thought this was like a maybe not tape even, maybe
like some kind of um like mesh, not mesh, like cloth cover. I
didn't I didn't think it was tape instantly, but it's obvious
there's something there, right? You can >> the round bump
under the tape. Yeah.
the I the lead I don't think the lead would be there. I don't
think that's a lead. Oh, hold on. Wait. There's there's a way
better Hutch clip today though. Okay. Have you guys seen Hutch
react to the Anakasparian?
The Hutch the Hutch Anakasparian. Let's just do a quick quick
little interlude here. Okay. Or a little bit of like way way
way overreading into things. Just the most motivated reasoning
ever. Hold on. This is This is [__] funny. Okay.
Okay, are you guys ready? Are you guys ready for this? This is
funny. I don't know if you guys have seen the Anakasparian clip
that's out there. All right, but it's very funny and it's
We'll just watch. We'll just watch.
>> I'm talking about like Yes, we're going to surveil everybody.
Everyone will be on their best behavior. Yes, you're a freak.
You're a total creep.
>> Is she imitating the meme?
Am I crazy?
Because at the bottom of the Chiron, they're talking about Israel.
Candace Owens reveals Kirk's text about pro-Israel donors.
Is she literally >> We all know that you could very easily
just go find the YouTube clip, right? Does Hutch do that? Maybe,
>> you know, the [__] anti-Semitic meme. Is
that what she's doing? >> She doing the anti-semitic meme.
>> Maybe Hutch goes,
>> listen. Hutch. Hutch can only redeem himself if he goes
and finds the full clip. Okay. >> I spent a lot of years
totally oblivious to anti-semitism. And to be quite frank with
you,
I didn't, you know, I thought I thought
claims of anti-semitism were like massively overblown.
>> Uh, they are. But hold on. He can save himself. Okay.
He just has to go and watch the full clip. And to be quite frank
with you,
>> I didn't, you know, I thought I thought
claims of anti-mitism. >> Okay, he continues on. I think
he goes and finds the full
>> I don't know, you know, like I
holy pogies, thanks. >> As they should be okay. >> Uh,
we are >> he's watching full segment
>> paused here. He's just paused.
might think he pulled the whole thing
>> Yeah. Now
I could have programmed that because like >> I thought
he did. Does he watch this? >> Kind of looks like AI. >> This
is crazy. >> Well, when I looked up opinions,
>> these pastors
are just >> Okay, so he looks it up. >> Not as honest
as they should be. So many people were racing to establish that
his legacy was anything but Catholic. >> Uh Ziggy, thanks
so much for 5 months, 5 >> He does the full video. It's
over like an hour visas.
We get to
>> the word Zionist too, you know, like
and and that was never uh never the thing for me. Like I always
understood what Zionism and anti-ionism was >> in an academic
sense.
Um it came up in in my studies when I was in college was when
I first learned what Zionism was. And um you know I
Okay, it looks like he watches the full thing, so he should have
a chance to recover here. Okay,
whatever this uh >> actions on,
>> it's got Hey, are you okay? And then watch Jenk's face
as she does it, too, by the way. Like, watch >> with this.
>> Larry Ellison can tell me how my ass tastes. Okay, how
about that? All right, disgusting weird oracle.
>> Watch Jinx face here. >> Founder going around
talking about like, yes, we're going to surveil everybody. Everyone
will be on their best behavior. Yes, you're
>> okay. It's
the context makes this seem worse than it seemed before. Okay,
I'll be real. The context was actually did not help. Okay, I
thought it was totally absurd. The context is like, oh, she's
talking about like a wealthy billionaire Jew now. Like literally
a literally a wealthy billionaire Jew.
>> Okay. Well, >> freak. You're a total creep.
>> bro. Shank's reaction is funny. >> Going around
talking. >> Wait, this is actually this is actually pretty
funny. >> Like, yes, we're going to surveil everybody.
Everyone will be on their best behavior. Yes. You're a freak.
You're a total creep. >> All right. Total creep. >> So,
my point is do not put Larry Ellison's actions on our friends.
>> No, I don't. I don't because idiots. Okay. I don't
>> uh I still I listen I still don't really think that's
anti-semitism. I just don't think it feels like that's not in
her brain, but
I can see how Listen, watching it in the full context, I can
see how somebody would think that. Okay, I can see how somebody
would think that.
>> Conflate a >> Oh my god, she just You can see
him a little exasperated, bro. I I think what I've heard reported
is that Jenk is like really defensive
when it comes to Anna. like he's really lo like that's what I
have heard is that he's really loyal to Anna
and like views her as you know like he's just like very loyal
to her but even he gets a little exa exasper well it's anti-billionaire
sentiment that's flooding through because Larry Ellison is getting
preferential treatment from the Trump government right in his
purchase of Tik Tok in the allowance of the merger of his son's
companies with uh the Paramount Sky Dance merger
He's getting like massively favorable treatment for sucking up
to Trump. >> Like hold on. My point is
he kind of like lets us >> like you you probably should
hate Larry Ellison. Larry not Larry Ellis but Larry Ellison.
You probably should hate that guy. That guy's down a little bit.
>> I put Larry Ellison's actions on our >> No, I
don't. I don't because I'm not an idiot. Okay. I don't >> Is
he Yeah, he's And he's also like the biggest I think he was the
biggest private donor ever to the IDF. like he is the largest
single like private donor or individual donor to the IDF.
>> Like he's like, "Oh, god damn it. She's >> I still
don't think you just say cuz she does the hands." Okay. I don't
think just because she does the hands you're going to call her
anti-semitic. Come on,
How do I donate to the IDF? I have no idea. No. No. I don't I
don't just call it anti-semitism because I fully believe that
Larry Ellison's like evil. Okay. evil trying to thwart democracy
in general. Soing of like a you >> you're a total creep.
>> All right. Total creep. >> So my >> can
tell me how my ass tastes. Okay. How about that? All right. Disgusting
weird
>> Watch Jen's face here. >> Founder going around
talking about like Yes. We're going to surveil everybody. Everyone
will be on their best behavior. Yes. You're a freak. You're a
total
dude. Dude, Jake's face makes this so much better. Oh my god.
Why can't I Hold on. I can't see him. What the [__]
What the [__]
>> All right. Creep.
>> dude. Okay. Somebody's got to start doing if if we're
running with this. Okay. There's got to be merchant posts with
Anna's face. Okay.
Like, um I I can't help but see it a little bit. I'm
Do I think she's intentionally doing it? I don't know that, but
I certainly see it. I >> We're going to surveil everybody.
Everyone will be on their best behavior. Yes. You're a freak.
You're >> uh Gringle. And nothing she said was wrong. Um
Larry Ellison is a weirdo who wants to surveil a bunch of people.
Nothing she said was wrong. I I don't like submitting to it being
anti-semitism when I feel like she's in the correct when she's
in the right. And a lot of people would do similar hand gestures
to mock like creepy people. Creepy weirdos. People they think
are like creepy weirdos.
I don't. Dude, I don't. Uh, Anal X, you're late. I already pointed
that out. Weren't there a lot of Armenians and uh, they don't
exist anymore? Wait, do they not exist because of the or because
of the Turks?
Are you just trying to shoehorn in an Armenian genocide comment
right now? That's lazy, but okay. Go off, king.
All right.
Did the House Oversight Committee meet with social media companies
today? No, that is either cancelled or not
We're not totally sure yet. Sorry, it's Sorry, it's either delayed
or cancelled. Delayed or not happening. One of the two. Not totally
sure which.
Could be either one. Hold on a second here. Okay. Could be either
one. Oh, just thinking she might have a touch in the gene pool.
I mean,
listen.
No, I can't I can't get any further down this rabbit hole right
now. Okay, I'm gonna throw up the H3 coverage. We'll check this
out for a bit and then we got other stuff to do today. So, we'll
check out some of the other >> because to me, I watched
this a couple times. To me, the dog is just being a
uh what do we got? We got Ethan. Ethan's going off with the people
in the H3 crew
going off about Hassan [__] and Kaya Gate. Okay,
caller gate, whatever we want to call it. Let's check out the
H3 response. And then I think what what else have we got? We've
got Fuentes and Dave Smith had a conversation.
Um
there's a couple new documents in the the tiny case.
And yeah, I think that's Oh, and the Cinder stuff possibly. >> It
is emblematic. >> Oh, guys, also I should say if you if
you like the content, go ahead give uh give me a follow on every
platform. Follow on Twitch, follow on Twitter,
All right.
Join the Discord. discord.gg/JSDLK.
And if you really like the content, you go ahead. You can throw
a couple subs my way. All right. I think we're something like
uh I think we're like six subs away from two more hours. >> Future
trying to learn Kyle or >> Oh, stop. Stop. Stop. We're
like six subs away from two more hours on the stream right now.
Um you can sub on kick, you can sub on Twitch, you can
donate. Exclamation point. Donate the chat. We'll give you the
Streamlabs links. The Streamlabs and Kickbot links. Okay. You
can give kicks on the kick platform as well. And with that being
said, guys, we're going to head over to Kick for the rest of
the stream. So, thank you if you've been watching on Twitch.
We're heading over to
It's kick.comjlk.
Head over there. Let's
let's continue on with the stream just in a little bit here.
Okay. See you guys in a bit over on kick. It's
Bye-bye. Hey, multireaming is off. We're over on kick only. Let's
continue. >> All of America's >> Oh, we got a hutch
tweet. the hutch tweet about. Was this about Anna or
see what the hutch tweet was about?
>> I'm talking
for those who don't know what the happy merchant meme is. What
an embarrassment Anna is. What a embarrassment Anna is. This
was genuinely shocking. I honestly had no idea how completely
insane anti-semitism makes people when it really starts to creep
into their psyche until I saw so many examples of it happening
in recent years. Kanye, Candace, Anna, etc. Dude, are we really
we're really going to put Anna Kasparian on the same She's on
the same plane as Kanye West and Candace Owens.
We're going to pretend that's a reasonable comparison. That's
kind of
That's kind of nuts. It's the brazeness that was so shocking
in this instance. She's very clearly invoking a well-known anti-semitic
image in this clip, and she unabashedly leaned into it so hard.
Sincerely shocking, lol. Uh yeah, it's um I wish I could comment
on Hutch's stuff, but listen, sometimes people just decide to
block you because other people lie about you to them, you know.
Amazing. Amazing. Amazing. Amazing.
He blocked you? Yes. Never hadn't really tweeted at him or anything.
He just blocked me because somebody is whispering in his ear
about me, I guess.
Very cool. Very neat. Very awesome.
Anyway,
uh let's go. Let's go over to the H3 stuff. >> Much more
consequential
violence.
Okay. It's the same reason as to why America Ka, please just
go. Just stop. Jesus Christ. What are you doing? You're being
such a baby.
It's just
you're making her stressed. I I I She just literally is is so
incredibly spoiled from my mom.
>> Now, let's look at the crucial moments here. Right as
she yelps in pain,
>> dude. That aiming animations thing might have actually
just ruined this for me. This is rough.
And like the aid animations or aiming animations thing might
have just totally ruined this. Like I >> The sun is clearly
reaching. >> I don't know, man. >> For a >> Wait,
there's ain't no Wait, does he usually have his Is there a dog?
Is there is there a dog on his stream? Why is there a dog there?
He bring his
>> she yelps in pain. >> All right. >> Han
is clearly reaching >> for a button of some kind. >> Look
at Look at the mannerism. Look at the stretching. >> Why
America ka please just [__] >> what do you
what else would you be doing in this body motion? He looks over
to the side. He reaches for something, right? And >> I
wish I I almost wish that I didn't have uh >> right as
he seems to be making >> I wish I wasn't going to I wish
I didn't have fun with stuff like this cuz I feel like I push
things in a direction when I review [__] like this
and I say like what's going on. >> You're kind of pushing
motion. That's animal abuse.
Tom came and he moved Ducky who was sitting comfortably.
>> I actually shocked him. Is that not >> You I left
my dog >> nothing. I just laugh because I like I pull this
up and I I lay out all the stuff and then >> shop callers
at home today. I thought it would be inappropriate. >> So
I was reaching for the button. >> Uh no, you're right on
time. >> So I was reaching for something. >> So there's
Tom, is there any other way to explain this body motion
at the exact time the dog yelps? >> America ka please just
go just stop. Oh, are they saying like I I haven't read like
anything. So his initial explanation is that she p she scratched
herself on the bed or something or a nail got caught >> at
the same exact time he like >> the same exact time he reached
for and and into what can be described as a pushing motion like
that body language is someone who's he's pushing something. >> People
are saying the cough is a tick. Yes. Yes.
>> What do you think you did wrong? Nothing. I'm just I'm
laughing that like I I pointed out all the body language stuff
and I just feel like I lean into that cuz I'm like joking. I'm
like trying to build a narrative, but I realize I'm trying to
build a narrative. I like don't hate this guy. I don't want to
uh I don't want to like destroy this guy. I'm like having fun.
I'm like, "Oh, look at this crazy [__] that's happening,
right?" And then I feel other people like do it. And I feel like
I've like leaned into it and I feel bad for people like using
it to want to destroy this guy after it's like just a joke to
>> but it's like it's like probably they didn't even see
it. Probably it's probably not a big deal.
>> Right. So he initially tries to lie and say, "Oh, she
must have got caught on the bed or something." Total just a
>> Jesus. Hold on a second. What the what the wait uh what?
Here we go. Here we go. It's the same reason
America ka please just >> now he gets angry and she recognizes
that she fears him >> and she immediately enough for Hassan
he needs to punish her >> [__] go just stop
>> why is he so angry >> that's a good point the
dog Ka was already going back >> yeah no it wasn't enough
for him >> so like why punish you punish for bad behavior
you don't use a shock but or you remove the dog from the situation
>> he because >> it was already Well, we'll get into
that. But I think he's sadistic. I think he's a psychopath. >> Well,
the other thing I didn't like >> I think he's exerting
I think he's exerting control on an animal. I don't think he's
like a serial killer, but in the same sense that serial killers
torture animals.
>> Okay. It's good to know we're starting off in the in
like a good psychopath. I'm not saying he's a serial killer,
but like, you know, he's right at the edge of he's right at the
edge of being a serial killer. Dude, that Aiman Animations video
actually like pushed this guy off the cliff. This guy was at
the edge of the cliff
and the aiming animations video pushed him off the edge.
Jesus. >> It's a It's an It's a
It's an assertion of control. >> Right. That makes them
feel strong, that makes them feel like an authority. And that
that's why he's doing it in my opinion.
My humble uh I do have a PhD in psychology and criminology. So,
>> and I'm also a financial trader, fully
>> Oh, I don't know if I explained, but
>> Wednesday is for members, and I love our members. We
when we finish this one story, we're going to do this one story,
and when it's done, we are going to go live for our dear beloved
members because we always come through for you guys cuz we're
so so grateful. So, thank you to our members. >> We didn't
forget about you guys.
But we're doing this special live on a Wednesday, which we don't
usually do shows on just because this story is honestly such
a big it it's big.
So, um,
so let's continue here.
Now, he says she caught her nail or something on the bed. If
that's the case, if my dog randomly yelped in pain, my instinct
would be to check on them >> for sure. Yeah. >> What
happened? >> Yep. Are you okay, dude? Ethan. It's so funny
that Ethan is going to do the same thing he's done in every case
and totally overplay any possible argument he has until he looks
like a complete fool to anybody who takes him seriously, which
is not very many people anymore, but like it is just the same
pattern again where he's going to lean into every possible thing
he can without validating anything, without thinking about it,
right? And and he's just going to look like a fool again. Hey,
the reason he doesn't >> um like if my dog ever yelped,
like I go over and check on it. Um Hey, what do you do if your
dog takes a [__] from the floor? We chilling? We
chilling? I think we chilling. >> Do that is because he
knows why she yelped. He did it. >> And the reason he doesn't
check on her is cuz he's angry at her and he's not wanting to.
He He's angry at her. He's doing this out of anger.
>> Uh he was annoyed with the dog. He was annoyed with
everything. And yeah, that's bad. Obviously not a good place
to be at as an owner. Obviously gonna lead to behaviors that
are bad for the >> You know, that's a good point because
if my dog yelped like that, I would go over and be like, "What's
causing, >> you know, pain?" Yeah.
>> Something stuck in his paw. >> He exhibits no
concern for his dog. None. In fact, the opposite. He He does
He not only doesn't >> I would say this is probably what
do you call it? Like the best maybe the maybe you could say this
is the best indication that it's a shock caller, right? That
he knows what the Yelp is from. that the Yelp was from either
a vibration or a shock or some kind of correction and that because
he knows that that's what it's from, he doesn't feel concerned
to go over and check. He's like, "Oh, you're just being a >> Doesn't
exhibit concern. He exhibits uh anger at his dog expressing pain.
>> The whole thing was very aggressive. I didn't like his
tone throughout this whole video.
>> Well, yeah. And if you go back and look at his repeated
treatment of his dog, it's been this way. It's only the shot
caller that got people to realize how psycho this [__]
is. But but just to look at it again here. So this this dog acts
so according to son this dog
>> nail got caught in the bed or something obscene like
that.
>> So watch his immediate reaction in the aftermath of
this fluke poor animal getting injured. >> It's the same
reason as to why America ka please just go. >> Why is he
so angry about one paw off? He's acting like this is the greatest
disappointment of his life. >> like his dog, how could
you do this to me, Ka? >> Yeah. It's like, bro, what?
>> And she's such a sweet, obedient dog. Like, bro,
>> hey, you was definitely being a diva for
>> So, here she yelps in pain right as he reaches. But,
okay, it's all a coincidence, right? >> I just I wonder
how Ethan feels.
Well, what am I I'm trying to remember. Do you guys remember
when he hit the button and it didn't work and he was kind of
like people were saying he was berating um AB?
Do you remember that? It feels like the exact same thing to me
where it's like you're kind of annoyed. You're a bit more of
a dick than you should be, but it's like it's not the biggest
deal in the world. And it's so funny that he could he can understand
that with himself and then with Asan he's like no no no. This
guy's like evil. This guy's like a totally this guy might this
guy's not quite a serial killer but he's like right there. He
likes like hurting animals to feel dominance actually.
>> go. Would you stop?
>> So, is he concerned about what she Why is she in pain?
Dogs don't just randomly yelp out in pain. It doesn't happen.
So, here's his reaction.
>> Jesus Christ. What are you doing? >> You're being
such a baby. >> You're being a baby. What are you talking
about? This is a dog. She just expressed that it's hurt and you're
calling it a baby. Dogs are babies, by the way. They have the
intellect of like five, six, sevenyear-olds. Dogs, the dogs are
our babies, right? And so, so when it's like I I'm in pain and
he goes, "Stop being a baby." It's like, "What is this?"
Yeah. I I think uh most most parents of like a younger child
have never ever like gotten a little annoyed with their child
and not been like infinitely understanding and caring at all
times. I think that's like the thing that separates good parents
from bad parents. If you're not perfect, if you ever kind of
like lose your temper, you know, not in a way where you'd hit
them, but where you're just like less caring than you should
be, that's definitely proof that you're like an abusive parent
and you shouldn't have a child. For sure. We've definitely never
seen like a otherwise good parent kind of just like have a breakdown
after a bad day at work and some getting and then they accidentally
let like the pasta boil over and then they get a little upset,
right? Maybe they yell at their kid for a second. They're like,
"What? Why can't you just go back to your room?" That's definitely
never happened to anyone. Definitely. >> Boot camp. >> Yeah.
Tough. Are we in basic training? >> Get with the program.
>> It's psychotic behavior. It is. Even if there's no shot
caller involved, what he's exhibiting here is this abs. Even
if there's no shot collar involved. Okay. I All right. If there's
no shot caller involved, he's like a little annoyed with his
dog.
Uh unjustifiably so. He's like being a diva because his stream
was crashing or whatever, which he admitted today. He literally
was like, "My bad. I shouldn't have done that. That was that
was really bad. I should not have done that to Kaa
anger at the most asinine
uh completely innocent reaction by Kaa and or um the pain that
she's exhibited.
You know, and it it really peppers in when you go back and look
at how she's I've always wondered how is it possible and why
is it even possible that she sits so obediently on this tiny
square for hours every day. This young energetic puppy
is possible, right? >> Why would you, dude? Uh Ethan is
literally sitting here like I just I actual dog
actual dog training. I have no idea. I can't even get my dogs
to take a [__] outside. I can't imagine how you could
get this dog to sit there for hours a day. It's baffling to me,
bro.
Dude, I That's like an insane. He doesn't even realize that he
sounds totally insane.
He He actually doesn't even It doesn't register one iota. He's
just sitting here being like, I just can't How could that dog
be trained? How could a dog be trained? It's It's almost impossible.
It's It baffles the It baffles the mind. I wouldn't even want
that for my dog. I would want to freed him to go outside, maybe
have a doggy door or something so he can go pee and >> have
someone take your dog out and play with them for sure. >> Take
them to a dog park. The young dogs, they got to get the energy
out.
but you know, the reason is you'll >> If only Hassan posted
a story every morning of him doing exactly that, >> Notice
Kaya is perfectly in frame for Hassan. This dog is a prop.
Her removing her stepping out of frame is an affront to him and
his perfect prop. This perfect story of her being this incredibly
obedient dog or or just this beautiful uh picture uh picturesque
life of this perfect dog owner. She stepped out, right? And that's
what's upset him. She is literally a prop uh in his background.
There's no there's no other way to explain this. Even if you
put the shot caller aside and say, "Okay, so I think this is
just belied by Kaia leaving like fairly often,
I like I understand. So you could say the dog's a prop and he
put the bed there because he wants the dog in frame and but it's
not abusive to have your dog stay somewhere with a command. That's
not abusive, right? It's only abusive if the dog is like expressing
distress, wants to leave, needs to leave, and you won't let it,
right? Beyond its like discipline level, beyond its ability to
do something like uh sit in a place for a couple hours.
I think it's more that he doesn't want her, but hold on. Cooking
a pizza. This I believe this was him
not wanting
dogs need water. I don't see water. I believe people do crate
train their dogs without water. Um, I would probably want water
around the dog, but I don't know. You could just ask a trainer
about this, right?
Um, and I think he lets the dog get up and walk around in other
streams without like freaking out on the dog. He was clearly
having something go on this day, I guess, with his stream canceling
who who the [__] knows what else. Or he was like,
>> and let's say she just happened to scratch herself at
the exact moment he reached for something. Crazy coincidence,
right? It's still
>> you know? To me, you'll see your kids are younger, but
when they get older and they're playing sports, he's got the
energy of a baseball dad. Your eye on the ball, you suck. It
seemed like that same aggressive type tone. >> 100%. Right.
>> That's what it felt to me is like a a um overburdening
uh father, >> like a son who's who's uh in little leagues
who gets hit in the stomach with a ball >> and doubles
over in pain. And that is like come on.
>> It's baseball. >> Get it together. You know, just
and you know that that's exactly what's happening here. There's
is just completely diluted.
>> It's just making her stress literally is is so incredibly
spoiled from my mom. >> Then his response is, I'm so angry
at my dog for taking up one paw off. And you know what? She's
so spoiled by my mom. She lets her m this dog roam around the
house that
I I would say it, but that's what Issa was thinking. He goes,
"Oh, that mom. She spoils my dog. She lets her roam around. She
She lets her drink water when she's thirsty." You know what a
what a terrible dog a manager my mom has
>> right? But of course, >> I mean, that could be
totally true. Obviously, like training a dog, having it professionally
trained and keeping it trained involves a level of discipline
that a lot of people don't like to do with animals. A lot of
people want something that they just like get affection from
and can give affection to that they don't really care about what's
best for that animal. They just want something that they like
give and receive affection from, right? They want like some emotional
sponge for themselves. That's what they want an animal for. There
are other people who want an animal and they will train it and
they will make sure that that animal's taken care of. It's like
way different. It's a way different relationship.
And I think I think it's totally fine to have either one. I think
it's mostly fine to have either one as long as you're not going
like crazy about them, right? Like as long as you're not um Yeah.
As long as you're not like getting way too overbearing in either
direction.
I don't know why
Assan was like I think if if I could find other examples of Assan
being like this like routinely with Kaya, I would get concerned,
right?
months and months of streaming. Of >> course, there's so
much more to look at. This is only the tip of the iceberg. And
this there's a reason why it has 65,000 points on live stream
fail and it's going mega viral because on its face, it's pretty
obvious what happened here. >> Before you go on, first
of all, I tweeted about this yesterday and have literally hundreds
of hater like DMs, which I don't even give a because you got
to stand on business. But when I text you last night, people
I I don't know how to explain it.
Listen,
if I go to what is it foy
like the the what is it? It's like a feminist or one of these
subs that hate Ethan, right? And there there's like a massively
uploaded thread.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Um we go to I think that's how you say it.
[__] me.
I dude I don't remember how to say it. Okay. [__]
me. [__] me. I thought I knew
Okay. Fwa. Gotcha. All right. Whatever. And they upload a thread
about the CPS thing and laughing at Ethan. That doesn't make
it correct, right? People, it being popular that Ethan would
say this, right?
knowing that like a whole bunch of like awful about him has been
popular on Reddit and a bunch of other places and he's just like,
"Oh yeah, well listen, there's a reason this is at the top of
everything. There's a reason it's blowing up. >> We'll
let a lot of slide." Anti-semitism, no big deal. Let let it fly.
Racial hatred
go wild. But you do >> uh um um denying uh supporting terrorism.
All good. >> Let's go. But you do not with dogs. White
people especially will lose their mind. They put Michael Vic
in jail, right? Let's not forget that. At the time, sending somebody
to jail for abusing a dog was like unheard of. It's like the
Yeah, it's dog. If you want to kick it or something, if it's
bad, all right, like I'll look the other way. >> but so
he better watch the
>> He broke the
It's Oh, no. Please don't do the the lawb breaking thing. Please
don't do the lawb breakaking thing. Please, please, please, please,
please don't do the lawb breakaking thing. Please don't do the
law break. The lawb breaking thing is >> This was the one
thing he could get cancelled for. >> Although, you'll be
surprised by the level of
>> Michael Vic. Michael Vic and Assan are basically the
same. I think I think Hassan actually has a factory, okay, a
puppy mill cranking out Kaya's 24/7 and then aging them up somehow
through some unknown technology because if he's like Michael
Vic, that means when that dog up, you that dog in the head and
bury it in a ditch. That's what Michael Vic did. Okay, Michael
Vic wasn't just I, you know, I shot colored my dog. No, Michael
Vic was, hey, you just you just lost a fight. Yeah, boom, you're
dead. Go die in a pit, [__]
Okay, Michael Vic was out of his mind. >> Delusions and
coping happening by his fans,
he really has them in this just unbelievably tight
um cultish
uh dedication to him. But
what was I going to say? Yeah.
Well, anyway, let's move on. We have so much to to look at here.
Um,
here is Son's immediate explanation
in the aftermath of this. Oh, I know what I was going to say.
You remember this documentary recently? It was a huge thing.
Don't [__] with cats. [__] yeah. But
dogs also have and potentially Well, it depends if you're a cat
person or a dog person, but dog people are just as militant,
just as caring. Americans love their [__] dogs. And
when you look at spending habits of Americans, even per capita
dog owners spend a fortune on their dogs, even more than cat.
>> Bro, I'm about to go I'm like really really close to
going and reviewing the the dog claims about this guy given the
level of stark that he's approaching right now. What What is
the truth of the
Like I I'm right there
because it's it's actually like so stupid watching him soy out
about this >> at owners duper capital. We I promise you
I would bet any if you could tally up all of the instances of
possible animal abuse, I would bet on Hassan [__]
being a more responsible and better animal owner than this guy
every single day of the week. If you could know that, if you
had that like mapped out somehow, who who says no? Who would
think Ethan is a better animal owner than Hassan?
I think that's insane.
>> Love our dogs. They are babies. We love them, right?
And so to see someone being just honestly just just cruel, right?
That's the one thing he could have >> Oh, I forgot about
him feeding his dog cheese until it died. Good point. Yes. >> Done.
Cuz he's done everything else. >> And no big deal. >> Yeah.
Nobody cares. He's like, um, he's even got he This man went on
camera and said, "If you have ever exhibited positive feelings
for the state of Israel, you are." >> Yeah. This guy literally
got told, didn't he get told by people like, "You can't feed
shredder cheese." And then he kept feeding the dog cheese and
it died of like liver failure, kidney failure. >> Not fit
to catch a dog walker. And he has these people so diluted that
Sam Cedar, a so-called proud, came on this show, looked me in
the face, and said, um, he um, you know, his son is doesn't mean
it. >> Why Why does this have to do with Israel or anti-semitism
at all?
>> It's not what you think, right? But so, but but here
we found the dog. The dog is This is it. We don't with dogs.
So, here's his immediate explanation in
>> Uh, no. No. I don't think I don't think he's earned
me looking it up. I think I think I'm going to apply the Ethan
standard here and just say these things. Okay. I'm going to apply
the Ethan standard. I heard this once.
I heard it. Sounds reasonable. Seems like he looks like the kind
of guy who would do that. Yeah, I think so.
Hold on. H3 Snark.
Shredder and Alfredo. Then Ethan blames the vet for not telling
him it's bad. I'm stunned.
What is this?
Yes, he he is on flea and tick pre prevention especially during
the summer.
>> Dude, the high sodium thing. I wish dude, one thing
that f I wish somebody would have told me that these small dogs
are prone to kidneys because I would have been so much kidney
failures cuz apparently like sodium is really bad for their kidney.
And I ain't never heard that. And I was giving Shredder like
cheese. He loves cheese. And I was always sprinkling cheese on
his food. And I just wish to. And I'm so at the stupid vet, too,
cuz I took him to the vet three times in the past year.
They says, "Trust me on this one." >> Do you guys think
Do you guys think the vet lied to him about this?
Interesting. Okay.
Um, hold on. What are we looking for? Dung Devil says, "Ether's
cook, but kind of weird that Hassan lied about the shot collar."
Sure. Kind of weird. Not evidence the animals abused at all.
Unlike Unlike of the apparent evidence there is of Ethan being
extremely negligent with the health, like totally negligent with
the health and safety of his animals.
I actually when you have clips like this that exist on the internet,
I don't know how you go about trying to police other people and
how they take care of their animals. It's kind of weird.
Kind of odd.
aftermath as he realizes heed up and people are starting to chirp
about it and it's getting posted on live stream fails to hear
oral arguments on Thursday
that new CBS >> is there like a LSF video or something?
Is that why there's like hella people coming in here and and
screeching?
>> Is that what's going on?
Oh,
classic.
>> You got to love it. It started on D, then H3, then LSF
is a classic pipeline.
>> They tried to pin this on like our community, bro. 65,000.
I'm not on Twitter, but I heard everybody's timeline was just
100% Asan dog stuff. >> Yeah. I I mean, when I saw an IRS,
but I'm like, of course. And then on live stream fals, I know
they're not Assan fans, but when I open Twitter, I can I've never
seen anything like that. Whereas every single post was >> like,
bro, he's trying to offkate like, oh, it's just the haters doing
their thing as usual. Ah, I I helped there. >> there is
a reason why everybody is reacting so strong. I cannot do this.
Trust me, I cannot force people to care about something like
this. I've tried. They don't >> time and time again. >> I've
tried so many times, you know, about things that I think are
important, but this is uh but anyway, here here's his explanation.
>> [__] doc, dude.
>> Yes, I am incredibly abusive
to the not only best trained. >> Not clearly not. I saw
that dog take a paw off that bed. Clearly not best trained. Clearly
not. And I heard if she does it again, euthanasia and the is
might be on the board here. It's so unacceptable. I mean, she
might as well just have like mold of an old lady to death. That's
what he's acting like. >> It's okay to feed dogs.
Uh, I'm guessing if I if I look it up, it's going to say that
it's non-toxic, but there might be additives that make it bad.
Can I feed my dog cheese? Oh, what kind of dog? Hold on. What
kind of dog was it? Oh, yes. Dogs can eat cheese in moderation.
However, there are some important considerations. Avoid cheeses
with high salt content such as blue cheese or processed cheese.
Oh, so like the first thing it comes up with is like actually
no, don't feed this kind of don't feed this kind of cheese to
that kind of dog.
It seems like the first thing it did was pop up and go, "Hey,
actually don't don't do it necessarily."
Wow,
that's crazy.
And he did shredded cheese, right? Which would be quite processed,
I would
Maybe not like maybe that means like cheese slice processed or
something.
Okay. All right.
Hold on. Hell Hellbent just sent me something. Okay. Quick update.
Hellbent getting in on the Hassan hatred. Trying to Is Hellbent
trying to get back in the uh Nicholas Dioro house? Is that what's
going on here? Let's take a look.
I get it. I get it. It's like Street Fighter.
I get it. I'll like it. I'll I'll throw in the chat here.
Uh where did this go? There. We'll throw in the chat. Thanks
for the Thanks for the meme, Helmet. Thanks for sending that
along. Cool, cool, cool, cool, cool. I never left the house,
man. Sure, whatever you say.
Happened. Well trained. Sorry. What? Who? Caesar the dog whisperer
is crying out and just terrified by the lack of uh
>> to the not only best trained >> but also the
best behaving and most spoiled dog on the planet. >> Oh
yeah, she's so spoiled from when Ka yelled. Yeah, she yelled
because she clipped herself on something when she was getting
off the bed. >> She yelped because now I I looked at the
slow-mo of this that just that just didn't happen, right?
And Hassan's policy, as I've said before, maybe people start
listening. He has a conscious policy to never admit fault. To
never admit to being wrong, lie, attack, off you skate, and gaslight.
And they're actually >> Oh, I could have sworn Hassan came
out today and said, "Actually, I reallyed up by not going to
check on her right away. Should have absolutely done that. I
was pretty off and I took it out on her." >> I thought
that was >> They're trying to sidestep this whole thing
by saying Ethan's a dog. If you think that's bad, well, Ethan's
a really bad dog owner. And it's like, listen, if you want to
have a conversation about me being a bad dog owner, that's okay.
What's that got to do with Hassan? Like, I couldn't imagine a
more obvious
He did try to hide. He was using a shock collar. Uh, I lean in
that direction. Yeah, I lean I lean that he knew it was the model
that comes with the shocking element. And even if he wasn't using
bad, if he showed it off on stream, I think so. >> Yes.
What happened? What Hassan did? Don't look at that. Ethan is
really bad. Look at all this how bad of a dog owner Ethan is.
Okay, what's that got to do with his son? Sure, we're both bad
dog dog owners. Okay, but why are we talking about me? Let's
talk about the guy who's, you know, has a million tweets. Why
are we talking about me? >> Why is he going to you? I mean,
this is >> Well, I think I think I would I'm bringing up
Ethan cuz Ethan's commenting on it. Ethan's unhinged and then
he made a whole bunch of unhinged commentary about what this
means about Hzan being a psychopath or borderline getting close
to a serial killer. Not quite there, right? And so I started
looking at it with this guy and it's like, "Oh, you did something
way worse to your dog.
>> Way way worse.
>> Attack denying." >> But the response isn't just
from H3 people cuz it's so massive. It's people who've never
even heard of you are coming after him cuz they just saw the
clip on Twitter. >> Well, that's his go-to. He either blames
cuz Destiny has pretty much been reduced to Ash. So So I'm the
new boogeyman. But he's um he's This is the classic thing, right?
This is part of the gaslighting technique that how he keeps his
um community in line. No, this is all a conspiracy, guys, by
Ethan and the hater community is all they're conspiring to create
this crazy narrative which don't believe your own eyes, guys.
Don't believe your own ears. So, he claims it got clipped on
on the bed. I mean, I'll just watch this in slow-mo >> of
America's much more consequential
>> Ignoring the fact that it happens exactly when he reaches
over >> reason as to why America Ka, please just go just
stop. >> Did that dog clip it? It's moving so slow. Cuz
it's scared. >> It's not moving fast enough to her. >> It's
moving so slow because it's scared.
Are we
We need to get on We need to get on the same page with our trash
talk, buddy. Okay. I'm saying I'm saying it's moving slow. You're
saying it's scared. Which Which is it? >> Hurt itself.
Like a dog can pull its nail on on a really unfortunate u fluke
uh uh um injury. He was on the couch and he jumped off really
fast cuz they're also super young, energetic puppies. and he
tore his fingernail off cuz it got caught on the couch. Now I'm
so I'm admitting that this can happen, right? But this dog is
moving extraordinarily slow. There is no way, right, that this
dog hurt itself in America. Ka, please just go. Just stop, dude.
>> At the exact time he reached for a
>> the coping is off the charts. It's absolutely legendary.
Uh levels of >> Wait, what? What does he think? What does
he think? Does he think Hassan has like a stream deck integration?
That would be really funny. Okay. Stream deck integration to
like shock Ka. That'd be pretty cool. >> dude. Even before
he hits the >> I might I might let it go if he had a stream
deck integration for it. Okay. >> Uh shot collar. The way
the dog got up, it was so timid. Like it knew she knew something
was coming, but like maybe she had she was just too thirsty.
Has
>> Is this a professional podcast? How is this guy's audio?
This guy's audio is totally up right now.
What are we doing here, buddy? You're coming through. You're
coming through a cardboard uh what is it? Like the the circular
tube that toilet paper comes on top of that's wrapped around.
Okay. Like the cardboard tube. The [__] going on,
>> Need to like wait anymore. Had a pee or >> So,
it knew it was going to get a wrath of some kind. >> The
dog's scared of him. And we have more uh evidence of that. People
have obviously now that people realize
that Hassan has been abusing his dog. they've gone back and kind
of reviewed the footage, right? And so, I mean, a lot of uh here's
a highlight reel 420 Blaze, by the way. Now, I'm going to point
this out without any additional explanation or context. You can
draw your own conclusions, but do you know what yesterday was
when this happened? >> October 7th.
>> I didn't say it.
>> October 7th.
>> Is that date special or is just another
>> uh day of October? No, it's it that's >> you end
up getting his uh Tom cancelled.
>> That's when I am joking. >> That's when attacked.
I'm aware. >> Oh, you are. Okay. So, I don't know. Why'
you make me say it? I was trying to be cool with it. >> Well,
I was I I was trying to protect Tom there. Thank you. >> You
made it worse. You all made it >> All right. My bad. >> But
it is it is a I mean, it did happen on October 7th. I mean, that
was the
>> Draw a conclusion you want from that. >> Also,
today was supposed to be the >> What do you mean?
There's supposed to be a hearing today with the Reddit, Discord,
um, Twitch
>> Honestly, I just I I'm so over the October 7th stuff
>> about radicalization and it got cancelled because of
the goddamn government shutdown.
>> It's so unfair, man.
>> See, Destiny throw more shots at Pixie on Twitter. Um,
I didn't I didn't see that. >> But it's okay because we've
got plenty to talk about. And hopefully they reschedu and don't
forget about that. Anyway, here's the compilation. >> Why
would I watch Ana cover the Hassan
I that is I have no idea.
I don't care about Ana. I have no obsession with Ana like Ethan
does. So, I'm just not
Yeah, I'm good. >> But it is emblematic of all of America's
much more consequential
violence. Okay. It's the same. >> I love this. The the
situation could be more ironic. He goes, "God, Americans are
so violent and America is such a bad place and I just hate America
so much." >> Reason as to why America Ka, please just >> Americans
are so violent. >> Just stop. >> Get back there,
dog. Like, dude, whoa. >> It's actually gotten to the point
where like if he's um if he's going to be coughing like this
much, it's so it's so offputting to the stream.
It's like every third syllable. >> Jesus Christ, what are
you doing? You're being such a baby.
It's just
you're making her stressed. I I I She just literally is is >> so
incredibly from my mom.
>> Yes. Here's 2019.
>> Say, "If you run right now, I'll [__] >> Oh,
what is this? Um,
so after sending out the pixie to a minor,
I guess Destiny's also saying that she scammed her ghost.
Cool.
Um, I just love if you know
this is like clearly unhinged.
It's clearly like an insane thing to say.
I wonder why
I just wonder why anybody would associate with this person. It's
just like very
it's like Yeah. I >> I will just What else do you say?
Right. What else do you say? >> Devil donated $3. Time
to rebrand from JSDLK to JSNRK.
Uh maybe
am totally I don't treat most people that way. I don't I just
I listen to him and he's like going so hard on Hassan just purely
out of like hatred. And I'm watching him like totally overplay
it. Totally bungle it again. If Hassan had done something actually
bad here, Ethan would be totally bungling it for everybody else
who covers stuff. Like he is just he is trying to provide infinite
cover to anybody he thinks is bad by being totally incompetent
at his job. And I'm kind of tired of pretending that anything
else is happening here. He's awful at this.
Oh, you guys didn't see the tweet. The tweet was just um it's
just like so boring. It's hard to even get like outraged about
it anymore. He says uh apparently Pixie scammed her give Seno
to have play money while her parents covered the costs. He just
keeps like making things up.
I feel like
ah, nothing. I I just I mostly don't care anymore.
How do I put it? It's like
I I can't shout it into the void. People just don't give a what
it is, I guess.
>> You like I'll actually you okay in front of everyone.
Stay.
>> No, Will, I didn't show that. That person is even I
I have a hard time like caring about what Destiny says. I don't
care about what Gollum says. [__] come here. Whoa.
>> That was pretty I've never seen that
>> That's un that is I listen I don't know all the various
ways to train dogs. I've never seen someone grab them by the
tail like that. >> And the thing is people can be like
uh he's kidding saying he's going to kill her. But he there is
a he seems >> but he says in a way there's a tone to what
he's saying that dogs understand tone. You know, they may not
understand what you're saying, but they understand kind of the
vibe you're giving off. And it's an aggressive angry >> Well,
and then also it leads into him angrily grabbing her tail, >> which
is I >> Yeah, a lot of people sent me that. Can we I I
will have to go find that after. I think I'll I'll probably go
find that at some point. The actual underlying clip or underlying
VOD for that, cuz I have a feeling with the way it's clipped
that it's clipped that way to make it look as bad as possible.
So, we'll see. >> Pretty sure unacceptable, though. What
context makes it okay? Um, I don't know. Like depending on the
tone, it might be something he think is not thinks is not bad,
right?
>> Unacceptable. That was crazy, >> [__]
Come here. >> He's angry.
>> So, we know he's willing to act out in anger against
his animal. We've seen it the example of it right here.
>> Oh, come here.
>> Uh, here's a Yeah, here's a note from from uh researching.
Pulling a dog's tail should be avoided because it's highly sensitive
extension of the spine that can cause severe pain. Wow. >> Oh,
wow.
>> I did not know that. I mean, I've never been tempted
to pull my dog's tail and I've never seen anybody do it. >> But,
uh, >> yeah. I I've never had any inclination to pull a
dog by its tail cuz every time you grab a dog by its tail and
like move it or anytime I've like, you know, accidentally stepped
on a dog's tail, yelps, right? I just I feel like I've never
had any inclination to pull on a dog's tail that way so that
it pulls back, right? I feel like I'd expect to get bit. Guy
just grabbed a pit bull by its tail.
>> this was from 2019 [__] Animal Crew 2 videos
leaked. Now, on its own, there's obviously I feel like it'd be
easy to handwave this. You're like, "Oh, it's one. It's just
one thing. He wasn't being serious. He grabbed his tail. He didn't
pull it that hard." Whatever. But, you know, people were calling
him out for this even back then.
Dog kept in place for over four hours. No water.
What's going on everybody? I hope everyone's having a fantastic
evening, afternoon, pre no matter where you are in the world.
I'm a biker and this is the Hosabi broadcast.
>> So here they fast forward.
>> That that dog looks so sad, doesn't it? Doesn't she?
>> And just realize this is an 8-year-old >> Hey,
it's this. It's the dog psychologist.
It's I' seen this on Twitter, right? A bunch of people getting
like dog psychology degrees and they do all of the body language
analysis. Okay, it's basically the green line analysis for dogs.
This is a young, energetic puppy. They need to run around. They
have so much energy to blow off or at least let it get up and
get a drink of water, spread its legs. Why such a small area?
Dogs like to get up and resettle like a couple feet away where
maybe it's hot there and they want to lay down on the tiles or
the wood floor somewhere else and cool off. And I mean, this
is a dog that's just has an incredibly thick uh obviously coat.
Um, apparently this wasn't 4-hour clip. I don't know how long
it actually was. Uh, but uh, just to be totally transparent,
I don't know how long this clip actually all of America is much
>> violence. Okay. >> Uh, guys, we are three subs
away from two more hours on the stream. All right. Three three
subs, two hours. Let's go. >> It's the same reason as to
why America, >> but we've seen this. So, the dog goes back
into its spot and he continues the
But this is every stream. You can pull up any stream of a song.
And I mean, we've all seen it, right? The the the motionless
420 blaze. Uh the motionless dog. Now, this happened this was
a >> Okay. So, we went through streams and we found that
every time she was getting up around 3 hours to go out like an
hour or so, we looked at So, when he says it's every stream,
he's just lying again,
Like we we just went and did it ourselves. Very easy to just
look this stuff up for yourself. >> Isn't happening now.
I don't Who's this lady? I know she's some political figure that
people know. You know the lady I'm talking about, Dan. >> I
don't know if it's that he doesn't take his inhaler or he just
I don't know what it is. >> Uh she looks
>> Jill Brand. >> No way. He had Jill Brand on her
stream.
>> I don't even know who Jillbrand is, but I think she's
>> Yeah. No, I don't think that's her. I I to be honest,
I don't I have no idea who >> So anyway, so whoever it
is, she's here to have a peaceful and interesting conversation
with Hon's live stream. The last thing she would want to do is
embarrass him, right? as a guest in his home. But she, as a dog
lover herself, she says, notices the tightness of the collar
and and and is so uncomfortable with it, finds herself forced
to uh make a comment. Jennifer Welch, it is. >> It's mainstream.
I love her. I think her collar is too tight. >> Well, it's
a >> it's a what he was going to say. Well, it's a it's
a obedience caller. It's a shot caller. But he stopped himself.
What was he going to say? It's a what? What possibly was he going
to say there? It's a what?
>> I don't know.
You have to you have to be able to get two fingers and I couldn't
even get one. I think you're choking her. >> She can't
even fit one finger under the collar. Now, the OB we know the
reason is cuz she does have an extremely thick uh coat. So, a
dog shock collar would have to be on extremely tight to make
the the required contact with the skin to to admit a shock, you
know, strong enough to make it yelp out in pain. So, that's obviously
the reason why it's on so tight.
It's It's cuz she has a lot of neck
>> Uh I think I I've heard that is a relevant thing that
like when you have a lot of like very like a lot of flesh and
or fur gives the dog more room to shake the collar off to pull
the collar off and you don't want that, right? I' I've heard
that. I don't know. I mean, this this guest is is clearly concerned.
>> Showing concern. Yes. >> You know, she did not
want to have to say that on the live. Now, Assan says the dog
pulled its leg or something. It's literally like she fell down
the stairs. It's giving that she fell down the stairs, guys.
Why does she have bruises all over her face and thighs and body?
She fell down the stairs. Don't ask. But okay, you guys want
to defend the abuser? Sure. >> Go to show me.
>> Um Oh, my bad. Poor poor girl. I mean, loosen it. >> I'm
so sorry. Why Why is it so tight? One You can't fit one finger
under it. >> And I'm guessing her fingers aren't She didn't
look like a large woman. She seemed petite. probably not that
thick. >> So, his reaction once again isn't to run to his
dog's defense, but to say, "Oh, it's a lot of neck meat." Whatever
that means.
I mean, it's still tight. I don't know what neck meat means.
>> You know what neck meat means? You You used to own a
bunch. >> Okay. Well, what? Okay.
What the Oh my god, this is so This was getting so boring to
me. And then Dan just came in to power bomb this guy for
>> What the Take that as a compliment, Dan. >> I
just I mean, facts are facts. It was kind of your thing. >> But
flesh is what the part that you're >> No, I understand.
>> Then being there being a surplus of neck meat isn't
it doesn't is an excuse for having a collar on type, >> right,
Dan? >> I I guess No, no, not really. No, >> you
just wanted to call me formerly fat. >> I think it literally
is though. >> Yeah, I didn't I just needed to chime >> Well
done. >> Tell me. And what? Whoa. What's next? Ompic Ethan?
>> No. No. Hold on. Did you not use very heavy set? >> I
take it as a compliment. I' I've lost >> There you go.
I didn't mean any >> Oh, boy. Okay. He's like taking it
totally literally. He is totally
Oh, look.
I I've lost it. It's gone. And he's like holding his chin out
as far as he can. He's I don't have it anymore.
>> Well, there's no waddle at all. >> I just saw
an opening for a little for >> There's definitely
If you jut your If you jut your neck out entirely, there's no
anything.
>> He He has it here. He's like, "There's no waddle at
all." And watch how hard
>> to make sure that it doesn't look like it's going to
back and forth. >> There's no waddle at all. >> I
once a week. I know. Bougie. >> Yeah, that is bougie. >> Lots
of >> Where is What? I get a What >> people do that?
>> No, I know lots of people do it. >> When I have
a I I like He does this thing and it's I hate when he does it.
It's so humiliating cuz I have I have a little bit of loose skin
or I'm just not muscular. He does this thing where he goes like
this. >> Wait, really? >> He He waddles my waddles.
>> He waddles it on both hands. I think he thinks it makes
it feel good or something, but I just feel like a [__]
loosekinned weirdo. He loves doing that >> Oh, come on.
It's not the intent. It's supposed to feel good. >> No,
that's not his intent. He's a very nice guy. >> Is he trying
to shame you? >> But I it's just it strikes me as funny
every time he does it. Like is there anybody that doesn't feel
insult? >> A gave a statement to the Hollywood Reporter.
What
he responds to Hassan [__] dog abuse controversy.
Critics contend the polarizing public figure used a shot collar
on his pet while streaming on Twitch, which he denies. Hassan
[__] the popular leftist streamer who's gained increasingly
Hold on. Can I go dark viewer on this?
There we go.
The prominent
popular leftist political streamer who's gained increasing mainstream
prominence since Donald Trump retook the presidency has become
embroiled in controversy over the treatment of his dog Ka
treatment of his dog Kaia perpetual presence in the background
of his feed his feed at his home in West Hollywood. A clip from
his October 7th stream went viral after viewers alleged [__]
who has 3 million followers on Twitch, as well as millions more
on other social media platforms, activated a shot collar on the
pet while seemingly frustrated with her behavior. [__]
has denied the claim, explaining that Ka in fact wears a training
collar that vibrates with an Air Tag.
Jesus, sorry, I got a reaction that I was not expecting.
um with uh color that by so Pikers denied the claim, explaining
that Kai in fact wears a training collar that vibrates with an
air tag attached and that she accidentally clipped herself while
rising from her bed when the incident occurred, which produced
a yelp that provoked particular concern. However, critics have
remained skeptical, zooming in on footage of what they consider
a telltale green blinking light characteristic of a shot collar
and circulated on an old video clip of [__] admitting
to owning one or and circulating an old video clip of [__]
admitting to owning one and describing it as incredibly effective.
Oh, so they they're buying into the propaganda. He says he would
never do it right in this clip. Somehow that got cut out but
cut out but okay.
Now people for the ethical treatment of animals is weighing in.
PETA in a statement to the Hollywood Reporter the advocacy group
says Hassan [__] was has denied using a shot color
on his dog and we hope that's true because shot colors are dangerous
and risk of burn wounds, chronic anxiety and displaced aggression.
He added, "Positive reinforcement is a far more effective training
method and don't doesn't betray our animal companions trust in
us." Oh, so it's nothing. It's literally nothing. It's actually
just literally nothing. Cool.
Cool, cool, cool, cool, cool. All right. >> Well, Tiffany
does that. I don't know.
It's fine. Anyway, so claims she pulled her leg. She fell down
the stairs. Except when you, you know, close zoom in, you'll
notice on this >> evidence of Assan trying to trying to
drown Ka.
>> Oh boy.
>> There we go.
>> He's so He's so dead. He's all right. >> Oh my
god. What a monster.
>> She all she wants. Look at Look at her eyes. You can
see the terror, the absolute terror in her eyes as he tries to
pull her back into the pool.
What a sick What a sick bastard. What a sick
>> Hold on. Hold on. We're going to try. >> Oh my
god.
>> Oh my god.
Oh my. >> Look, look, look at her. Look at her reach back.
Look at her reach back to get any paw on land she can. She's
begging Hassan to stop.
>> Oh my god.
>> Jesus. Sorry. Sorry. Oh my god. That was Oh my god.
>> It up. This right here. This
>> Oh my god. >> No. Don't Don't take me out into
the water. No.
There we go.
>> Oh my god. >> I I'll leave it zoomed out. Oh,
I'm interrupted again.
>> Dunked. Dunked. She's getting dunkked.
>> Look at her. Look at her paddle in
This is This is a clearly frantic response. It's definitely not
what dogs do the instant they feel their their chest go below
water. It's not what dogs do instantly. It's not a ingrained
>> You're doing great.
>> That's your first time in the pool. >> I'd say
that was a relatively successful
Oh god,
that's uh
I apparently people are saying that this is abusive. Apparently
I haven't seen it. Father, please no.
if you have a pool and you don't train your dog, you're a bad
owner. That could be true. Yeah. Yeah.
YouTube Shorts redirect is a game changer. Um, I don't think
I have uh tamper monkey installed on this. So, but I I'll take
it under advisement. Okay, back to Ethan. >> Caller, there's
flashing, which indicates to us in this caller, right? So, here,
take a look.
>> In the same positive association with Israel. So, all
this does is breed. >> You see that the white part isn't
flashing. There's a large white like receiver, but under >> Oh,
hey, look.
H I'm guessing there's going to be a lot of thirst posting like
this that has gone under the radar. Okay. Sorry everyone. Han
is saving the shot color for me instead.
Jenna Yowi. Of course.
Of course.
Of course. Yeah. Of course.
I worry that most annoying people on the planet are on the way
to your replies. Queen. I fear you are correct.
This is This is rage bait, but it's Oh, it's ogre boy.
Okay.
Uhhuh. Uhhuh. Uhhuh.
Don't Don't cheer for these people. Don't Don't
cheer for it. There's a small flashing light. Did you see it?
>> I didn't see that. I just saw the white >> look
under the big white circle. >> Okay. In the same positive
association with Israel. So all this
>> everybody saw it cuz it's subtle. The first time I didn't
see it, I was like, I don't see it. Um, here there it is. >> There
it is. >> Frame for frame, guys.
That's there. That That's an electronic, right?
>> what's next is on. Was that a [__] Let me
guess. It was a weather balloon. Uh, refracting uh, you know,
ray of sunshine through your blinds. >> Could be a fitness
tracker. >> Could be. >> Count the steps. >> Yeah.
Like, let me tell you, not a lot of steps.
>> She's not the uh the Hassan response is up at this point.
>> Meeting her step requirements for the
>> you know. So, >> the chat is very delighted by
the fact that your massage therapist wax around. >> I'm
sure you guys are. >> Well, there's people saying, "I've
had a lot of massages. I've never seen somebody do that." >> Well,
I've never had that done on me
>> I think that's like a signature >> He's a very
talented. >> Oh, I don't doubt it. I don't doubt it. Yeah.
Maybe >> I do for you guys pleasure >> because I'm
a man of the people and I share everything in my life. >> A
man of the people who gets massages once a week. >> People,
dude, I am sorry, but people do >> Who? Nor. >> Uh,
you're right. I mean, I imagine >> it's not that
I think some people get massages pretty often um if you have
it covered by your health insurance, right?
I know plenty
I know that Gabe goes. >> Yeah. What do you think Gab's
doing at the massage parlor with the bars on it? >> I mean
>> you How do you think the same getting his underarm meet
waggled around? I I am well aware. >> You think it's millionaires
keeping all these uh shopping bot masseuse places with bars on
the windows open? That's an unhappy. There is those are working
class type of dudes. >> But didn't Robert Craft, owner
of the >> he's not a man of Orchids of Asia. >> I
remember the name cuz it's so obscene. >> Why whack it
and not rub it?
>> Like I feel like >> why whack it?
>> Whacking it. >> No, I agree. I see what he's saying.
Like, you know, >> I maybe g
>> the underarm fat. Not Oh, why doesn't he whack Ethan's
underarm fat? Apparently,
>> here's what I'm doing, guys, because I'm a man of the
people. And what Asan has shown you here is how willing he is
to knowingly and immediately lie to you cuz he knows admitting
to it would on one hand be the correct thing to do. And in many
people's eyes, the obvious thing of what happened, when I'm wrong,
when I'm caught out, I admit to it because I am an honest person
to a fault. I'm honest about everything because I believe honesty
is the policy. Honesty is growth. Good things come out of being
honest with people. And I I myself am I think a type of I think
it's good to show people you can be honest in life. And when
you're honest, it shows that your intentions are good. Even though
we do make mistakes, I'm not ever here to hide anything. Han
is I've tried
>> to convince you guys. Maybe this is going to help. He's
a liar. He lies about things. He lied about having a housekeeper,
which I said, right? He had He lied about adopting Kaia, which
I said he bought Ka, and he has a full-time housekeeper. He lied
about both those things. People called me insane. He's a liar.
I'm honest. I mean, the record speaks for itself. >> Well,
the reaction is so weird. Like,
>> I don't know about that. I feel like possibly entirely
possible he's lied about things. All right.
I just I feel like I've seen Ethan either Ethan is either like
a liar or he's so negligent he probably shouldn't have a show
where he gets like this big an audience. >> Like if you
were over my house and you said, "Dude, your dog's collar is
way too tight." I'd be like, "Oh, let me check. I didn't realize.
Like, let me loosen it It's neck meat.
>> Which means I >> It's always on that tight. >> And
he's kind of fat shaming a dog at the same time, too. >> Yeah.
Neck meat. >> Who feeds it? We don't do that anymore. He
did this on,
>> you know, overfeeding it. Proxy munchousing by proxy.
>> You ever seen that before on a dog? I don't know if
it is a thing. Might be
>> might be plotting to him. I don't know. >> I would
>> to get to be get get free. Anyway, I forget what my
point is.
>> Talking about massages once a week. >> Yeah. me
being the man of people, >> bro. Maybe Ka gets out of the
color every day. Um, well, Hassan just said that he's got multiple
colors for Ka and he's going to do a video on how he's got multiple
colors. What those multiple colors are, right? >> Being
honest to a fault. Next time I get a massage, >> seems
to be the case that he would have different colors for different
things. I don't know what they'd be. Maybe there's one for like
swimming. I have no idea. >> I'm going to film it.
>> I'm going to film it. >> Home in there. >> It's
in my He comes to my home. >> man of the people, bro. Oh,
you're just a man of the man of the people. >> Listen,
I know normal people they have massage massuses come to. It's
not that >> No, no, my apartment building actually offers
that. Um, surprisingly, I was kind of shocked to see that. Yeah,
they have some like service offering >> it. I don't know.
I've never done it. >> the price? >> It would It's
kind of expensive. >> How much? >> I don't know how
much I saw it when I first moved in. So, Mine is not that it
being more money than I wanted to spend. >> How much? Tell
me cuz I'll tell you how much mine is. >> Just you tell
us how much. >> I don't I don't know off the top of my
>> So, he comes to my home. He brings a table, right? He
for it's $90.
>> I was I would get >> from memory. I was going
to say it was like $80 or $90 or something like that. So it sounds
about >> for coming to my home and bringing a table and
doing all that. I think that's actually a really a fair fair.
The h of course obviously >> 20 under the pillow. >> The
waddles the happy ending. >> There you go. >> It
makes me extremely jubilant. Well, luckily for you guys, I am
bougie and I'm going to film him waddling my arm fat for you
guys. Yeah. So stay tuned for that.
Honestly truly regret letting you guys hear that story. Continue
on with that story. Okay. I apologize. That was negligent on
my part. >> Is in the same positive association with Israel.
So all this does is breed.
>> We saw it. Oh yeah. We we saw it. That's an electronic
caller.
Now he t So there's a previous clip now.
>> This is an old clip obviously, but he admits to owning
a shocked caller. A shock collar. >> Everybody's surprised
by how cheap that that is. >> Yeah. 90 bucks. That's what
I'm saying. It's not that bougie. I guess it's >> very
accessible, you know, and people >> Everybody's like, "I
should do that." >> That's what I'm saying, right? >> I
feel like >> that's really not >> I guess I'm just
not a massage guy, so I >> Wait, what?
What? Watching you back.
Hold on. Watching you back has just alerted me to the queen Britney
Simon
giving her take on Kaia [__]
Did his son actually abuse his dog or are the worst boys at it
again?
>> There's like this weird He reacts weird. Like it's a
weird reaction for me, but I wonder if it's a This is going to
sound really weird. I wonder if it's like a boy reaction, like
a misogynistic reaction almost cuz Ka is a girl.
>> Hysterical [__] Ka per. Okay. Hysterical
[__]
Constantly constantly whining. constantly howling about her problems.
>> Don't even get me started on veganism and feminism.
Okay. Don't even get me started on the exploitation of female
bodies as an animal. Okay. But like maybe it's like >> as
an as an animal, >> a guy thing. Yeah. Because like a lot
of guys I see who own animals think they're more manly if they're
not as attached to their animal and or they think shot collars
are just like a part of being dominant over the animal. Okay.
So, like I'm super anti-shot callers for the record. I think
they're abusive. I think they're totally wrong and they're unethical.
But a lot of the people in my life who've ever used shock collars
have been men who claim >> So, like again, it's just going
to depend on what she means by shock collar, right? Like there
could be a shock collar that is like the the e-collars, right?
That's not what I would classify as a shock color, okay, at all.
Uh must be an Arab thing.
Uh, Arabs love showing dominance over I >> They're like
doing >> I'm not going to finish that. I'm not going to
finish that. >> I've always said this really up. You shouldn't
do that. You shouldn't get a shot caller. I've never known a
woman to buy a shot caller. >> It's like literally I've
never seen it in my whole life. Now that I'm saying it doesn't
exist, but it's a man thing. Like men I know buy shot collars.
Now,
most of the men I know who bought shot collars at some point
also regretted it eventually.
Okay, so that's the other thing. Okay. >> Doesn't look
good at all. >> E-collar and shot collar are the same thing.
No, shot collars generally only have a couple settings. E-collars
are
not providing like a an electric stimulus. It's like a what do
you call it? Like it's um it's not how do I describe it? It's
not the same thing. It's like different,
right? And it's not it's because it's so finely tuned. You're
never going to like nuke your animal. It's not very cut and dry
what happens, but he seems to reach over. >> Men I know
buy shot collars. Now, most of the men I know who bought Shaw
collars at some point also regretted it eventually.
Okay, so that's the other thing. Okay, >> doesn't look
good at all. It's not very And then she just yelps as if something's
really hurt. So, firstly, I don't understand his reaction. She's
literally just stood up and then he just like reacts in this
very exhausted manner like, "Oh my god." like she's actually
just
>> um how do I describe it? It's supposed to cause like
a what is it? A pressure. Is that what it's supposed to be?
But it's not like um it wouldn't be like a cattle prod or something
like people think of it as a like a cattle prod.
It's like it's very different. >> Okay. Wait. Great point.
Chatter says, "I'll admit I'm a biased fan, but it would be weird
for the mass to finally slip all of a sudden when the shock collar
in question hasn't even been mentioned for years." Okay, that's
what I was saying cuz I did think about this. Um because even
though I'm the only thing I'm actually upset about is that he
didn't get up to check on her because my brain is like, "Hey."
But also, um people don't do things that make sense sometimes.
So maybe he didn't think about it. Also, um I wonder if he felt
ashamed or kind of embarrassed that his chat was watching him.
You know what I mean? Like maybe he felt like he doubled down
almost. Like I wonder if it was almost like a PDA trigger where
he knows people would want him to go check on Kaa and because
people wanted him to check on Ka, he's like no. Do you know what
I'm saying? Maybe there's something like that. But either way,
I would love an
>> Um, just to point it out, uh, if you guys haven't watched
it, I'll link it in the chat just so you guys can watch it. I
have some people like really invested in in this being like horrible.
I'll just link you, uh, Lykan's video where he shows that he
has this exact collar. Exact color. It's like not even a problem,
right? That it's like pretty commonly used in training and there's
not like a super aggressive shot collar that hurts the dog.
My doll hairs, you're completely
uh I don't know what else to tell you. You're just completely
wrecked.
>> I just wouldn't >> Whoops. Wrong video for why
she yips >> cuz she would just yip out of nowhere.
You know what I mean? So, I would want to know that. And I think
that
from my
Hassan has been very loving to Kaya and I've never known him
to be neglectful to Kaya. So I I don't have any evidence. Though
L will go over some of the other parts of Hassan accusations
that I think are important. But I I want us to remember this
isn't even about Hassan. This is actually this is why I'm using
L's video to have this conversation because it's about animal
cruelty and the relationship we have with animals, non-human
animals in general, right? as a person that wants to harm reduce
and I think that's so important. It's >> I recall correctly
is an entirely different model. Oh, I thought it was like the
same name almost precisely. It has exactly the same um like everything
about it is the same
>> both of which were way too high. And the >> and
then he's got like the >> all you're trying to do >> this
remote or whatever. Micro educator. Micro educator. I thought
that's what it was was literally micro educator.
Uh hold on. Micro Educator. Uh, this is
Oh, hold on. Is this for small dogs? So, it's the same brand,
exact same thing. It's for small dogs, though, right?
This is like the This is like the exact No, it's the exact same
brand with like the same kinds of receivers or same kind of receiver.
Yeah, this is this is like the exact
exact same brand, exact same idea.
It's not about having an exciting moment to dunk on Hassan. You
Ethan crazy fans. It's not like Asmin Gold cares about Ka. He
cares about dunking on Hassan. You
It's not like you give a about the precious doggo in question.
Here on this channel, we only care about Ka. I do not care about
Hassan. I do not care about Ethan or Asmin. We only care about
Kaia's well-being. And the question that we need to ask ourselves
is was why did Ka Yip and does she need help? Okay. four or something.
>> Jesus Christ. >> She got a lot of dislikes.
>> Yeah, I'm guessing she's got like trolls who go around
and download her stuff. >> You're being such a baby.
It's just
You're making her stressed. I I I She just literally is is so
incredibly spoiled from my mom.
No, she doesn't want to come over here to see what's up. She
just wants to >> Okay, I don't know if we got anything
else for Britney here. >> When I saw that price, I was
like, "Ah, that's too much money to spend on
>> may wanted to use a shot caller
>> Oh, is he going to use the edited clip? Hold on. >> So,
here's an old clip of his son admitting to owning a shot caller.
Although he says he doesn't use it, he owns one. Instructor >> may
wanted to use a shot collar
um fish and his dogs
um for fish and his dogs barking. I couldn't do it. I have it
still. I bought it.
They are incredibly effective. How do you know that?
>> Oh, he says they're incredibly effective, but I just
couldn't. Sir,
>> so
now write it somewhere. I don't know. >> Now, obviously,
he says he hasn't used
>> Imagine taking eight years of your life caring and raising
a dog for other people to pretend like they care that it's uh
their adopted pet now. Like it's their adopted pet now. Well,
I think I think the sad thing is, yeah, you spend all this time
with this dog. You spend all this time raising this dog, training
this dog, taking care of it, right? And then people come along
when you have like one moment where you're like booty bothered
about how your stream crashed and they use that bad moment to
say this is how you are with animals. You're actually like you're
kind of like a psychopath who likes just having dominance over
animals where like you're just you be physically dominant over
animals because you have a huge ego and you're like a narcissist
and and a narcissistic psychopath who who just wants to feel
power.
It's like, okay, that's probably the most insane thing I've ever
heard. >> But what this clip does prove without a doubt
is that he knows what a shot caller is. He thinks that it's in
quote incredibly effective. And not only that, he owns one. Okay.
Now, in the context of everything we've just learned, this is
pretty damning, right? But there's more. Dog goes back to its
place with just one look. This one shows you how scared this
dog is of him.
>> Look at this. and he's pledged to to become a comp troller
in Illinois or whatever I think is is insane. >> So once
again, >> it makes people more insane when they hear this
kind of demand because they go because they don't have the same
tiny pad of loyalty or the the same positive feelings and the
same positive association with Israel. So all this does is breed
resentment against Israel and also depending on how
>> that's an abused that's like an abused >> And
look, he's got she's got his her back to him like she's
>> that's crazy. >> People think this is cool. This
is why >> this is totally fine, right? This is totally
a dog knows that you've said, "Hey, go to your place." And the
dog's like, "Well, I'm supposed to stay here." And they sort
of do this like little waddle off and and the dog like spins
around. It's like, "Oh, I I'll just go back. I'll go back. I'll
go back." By separately, it's funny. >> My theory on why
he's accidentally leaked so many nudes to people so many times.
It's part of the same pathology. He thinks it's cool. He thinks
it makes him look cool. Like he's in control all this different
stuff. He he this he thinks this makes him look like some kind
of >> bro. He's like become the aimman animation skit like
completely. He has like totally merged with the caricature that
Aean did for him and it's there's like no difference any like
the coughing is just it's consumed him entirely.
>> Well, so many times it's part of the same pathology.
He thinks it's cool. He thinks it makes him look cool like he's
in control. All this different stuff. He he this he
thinks it's so cool
thinks this makes him look like some kind of >> Hassan
leaked nudes. Um, Hzan apparently has I think what the allegation
is is he lets people look at his phone and they scroll like his
uh photos or whatever and they see nudes in there or he'll be
opening up send him nudes unsolicited
and then he like is not like hiding his >> Cool. In control
I've seen and frankly up until this moment people nobody had
a a complaint about this blatantly pathological behavior.
Dogs have more freedom in the pound.
Literally. Literally.
>> That's crazy. >> It's cra Yeah, that was crazy.
>> True. I bet Kyle would rather be in a pound right now.
Scheduled for termination in a week or two. I think that that
seems reasonable. That's a reasonable thing to say. >> That
was crazy. You guys, did you guys see that? That dog was acting
crazy.
That dog is acting up, man.
[__] >> dude. I just looked it up.
for a 60-minute massage through this thing that my building off.
>> Dan's like, "That's cool. I didn't pay attention to
any of that." So, I just looked it up through my through my apartment.
A massage for me costs Good one, Dan. Ah, good one. Uh, real
quick tweet. Real quick tweet. In a shocking update, Hassan's
do a local dog whisperer has thankfully translated the message
for us. What is this?
Continuing continuing on.
>> That is expensive. >> Yeah. That ain't worth it,
right? >> G-spots in my >> I actually missed >> my
my water. >> You said something. >> That's why he
was recommended to me. >> Okay. Let's get Let's get back
to the dog stuff. Okay. >> I'm sorry for interrupting about
the >> We're going to get a really good It's going to be
That's true. That's true. >> But if you make lunch recommendations,
you can write it to me.
>> So that's all extraordinarily um
uh circumstantial evidence. Right.
>> Here he is. A song getting mad at Kaya for getting up,
which we know the song considers to be an absolute cardinal sin.
How dare you stand?
What do you want? Okay. Okay. Fine. Fine. You can get off. >> Why
is he so angry at this poor dog? This dog is so sweet. If a dog
came if my dog one of my dogs came up to me when I was when I
stream like that looking for some attention, I'm I'm overjoyed.
I'm thrilled. Yeah. >> What a beautiful what a what a precious
>> Well, just a bigger question. Like I don't watch all
of Hassan's content. Like I I'm not part of this world. But like
why is he so angry? The dude you said he's got a housekeeper.
He's a multi-millionaire. He's got a successful YouTube channel.
Everyone glazes him in the media. Like I don't know. Girls are
sending him a nudes all day. Like what's the problem he >> This
is the part that's so maddening is that on its face he has issues.
He treats his chat like this. He yells at his chat. He just don't
care. And you'll see people hopefully will make start making
compilations of just how unhinged he is. How >> I like
the I like the pups aren't props. Okay, I don't know if you guys
can see this. Hold on. Can I go like the pups aren't this one
right down right here? Pups aren't props. >> Gross of a
human being he is, but you can see just how angry he's getting
at his poor defenseless sweet dog who's just coming to him for
the just a small amount of attention. What does I'm curious what
does Alfredo think about
You don't have that. What about Ducky? What does Ducky think
about this? He don't have that either. No. >> Well, we
we'll check in on them later, right, Nate? Or no?
>> So, anyway, here's a compilation of of him getting mad
at his dog.
>> These people are allies.
By the way, >> is he calling yelling a troll? I I'll be
honest. I was not listening to him just now. Is that what he
was saying? Was he saying like Hassan shows he's abusive through
the chat or something? I was getting the protester images at
the bottom of the stream lined up. >> Oh boy. Hold on.
>> Why is he so angry? The dude you said he's got a housekeeper.
He's a multi-millionaire. He's got a successful YouTube channel.
Everyone glazes him in the media. Like I don't know. Girls are
sending him a nudes all day. Like what's the problem he has?
>> This is the part that's so maddening is >> on
treats his chat like this. He yells at his chat. He abuses his
chat. And people for some reason >> I abusing your chat
is not a sign of any anger issues. Okay. And I want all the people
that I yelled at today to remember that that I'm not abus Okay.
>> Just don't care. And you'll see people make compilations
of just how unhinged he is. >> How gross of a human being
he is. But you can see just how angry he's getting at his poor
defenseless sweet dog who's just coming to him for the just a
small amount of attention. What does I'm curious what does um
Alfredo think about
You don't have that. What about Ducky? What does Ducky think
about this? He don't have that either.
Well, we we'll check in on them later, right, Nate? or no.
>> So anyway, here's a compilation of of him getting mad
at his dog.
>> These people are allies.
>> By the way, this was posted by a fan channel. They don't
care. They think this is amusing.
Hassan shock Oh, wait. No, when was this posted? One year ago.
Hassan shocked Kaya. ignores command. They thought this was cute.
One year ago. Self. She is self-aware that rules mean nothing.
I love the clips when the music that I can only describe as Ka
up to mischief. Do you see how they're trying to explain it away
like it's >> Wait, did he really shock her? >> This
is from one year ago. No, saying he was shocked. >> Yeah.
Is it? Oh, >> she dared to stand up. >> I love this
clip. Dogs are just like that. They get moody.
They don't care. Ka, no, you can't do that. They do not care.
This is
>> Wait, did he
Am I missing? Did he like play the clip? I thought he basically
just hasn't played any of the clip.
There's not that might be a little unproductive, but they are
still ultimately on the right side. Okay. These people are allies.
>> So, I just want to I just want to mention something
here. What do you want? Okay. Okay. Fine. >> Fine. You
can get off. >> He's genuinely angry
>> and and
he's genuinely what see more of it >> that so that you
see that it is >> just completely. >> He doesn't
even let her sit up. She's on in the approved area.
>> He doesn't even let her sit up.
>> But that's not enough. He needs total obedience. She
He She's not allowed to sit. She has to sit down. Lay down. >> I
commented before, but like imagine what happens off camera. Like
we're seeing all this, but like what do you think happens when
the camera goes off? Like he's like playful on the floor playing
with her and like having a good >> Listen, maybe I mean
maybe, right? >> He probably does love the dog and they
share good moments together, but there's clearly something else
going on here that is very cruel and totally unacceptable, right?
>> Which is kind of like an abused relationship. They go,
"Oh, he's not like that. He's great. You don't know this side
of him. We have great times. I love him. He loves me. I mean,
it really there is a lot of parallels between the two. It really
is a It really is.
>> Applied to great. >> He's angry. >> I don't
know why. >> He's angry. >> Why is he so angry? >> He's
not like proud of his like obedient
>> You see that it is >> just completely applied
to grade >> Oh, apparently he's tried a couple different
raised up beds for for this >> I got to take Kai out to
pee. Okay.
>> She very clearly is chirping at me. Somebody's bored.
>> She's She's bored. >> Come here.
>> You big old baby. >> How How is he going to How
is he going to make this seem like Ka is being abused here? How
do you do it? I need to know cuz this is this is some incredible
>> I love her so much. >> Oh yeah, I'm sure you do.
>> Oh my god, bro. >> I mean, he's overcompensating,
right?
Like he he's shown being exhibiting unacceptable behavior and
I love her so I mean, he the people buy it. They really do. >> Do
you want something to drink, by the
can we get you to stop coughing into the mic for two seconds?
>> I No, I'm okay. I have some water or >> The baby
goat. You don't want to even know what he >> Oh. Oh, he
caught the He caught the shade there. I have my inhaler. That's
not an answer to the question. Can I get you some water or something?
Can I get you a drink? >> Does says about this baby goat?
He laughs as it sent to slaughter. I'm kidding. I don't know
what it is. I'm kidding. I'm kidding. You believe that though?
And this is what people go. They go, "The fact that you believed
that says all you need to know."
>> But moving right along, more
>> Say something totally insane.
No, it's not true. But the fact that you like kind of believe
that it could be true. Doesn't that tell you a lot? >> Doesn't
that doesn't that say a lot? >> Evidence that isn't that
interesting. >> The son says he does not care and the issues
they come with despite owning.
>> I don't know if I think it's not exactly a pureate.
It's like some hybrid, but definitely a highly um designer dog,
very expensive designer dog that that he absolutely without a
doubt bought. Once again, to remind you guys, the story he tells
is that he was looking for a dog and he magically happened upon
an ad on Craigslist in which they in Los Angeles where designer
dogs are very popular and very in demand happened to be giving
away a very expensive designer dog for >> Wow, what a steal.
>> Can you believe that? show the post explain who they
were or how he had had such luck. No, >> she just magically
appeared one day. He didn't buy her though. He didn't buy >> Uh
uh, apparently we're going to tie in his appar I think he lied.
Seems like he lied, right? He got the most expensive dog breed
and uh he adopted it. But like apparently that's going to tie
into the abuse. It's >> just such a lib ass like oh dude,
please don't get a Frenchie. I just read a Fox article talking
about how problematic they are. Like I don't give a I know they
have breathing problems. I know they're incredibly bred. I don't
give a >> That is insanely callous. >> What? What
do you mean you don't? >> There is actually like a serious
issue with Frenchies being like >> they have a lot of health
issues. >> They're like born into suffering. You know,
imagine being born and you can't breathe and you're like, "Wow,
are like they can't swim. They drop like bags of >> Wait,
a dog that can't >> Frenchies can't swim. They >> That's
a fact."
But the callousness, >> by the way, I didn't know what
this clip was about. I didn't realize it was about French bulldogs.
That's actually way funnier that he's like, "I I would I would
want one anyway. I don't care if they have issues. That's like
a little bit that that makes that clip way different for me.
I thought he was saying something else. I thought somebody painted
that as like I don't care if the dog's choking. I But yeah, I
didn't I didn't see that was about French bulldogs. >> That's
the exhibit to dogs. Like as a dog lover, nobody would I would
never exhibit this indifference to to a dog. Even you know that
Frenchie. They're dogs. Who cares if they can't breathe if they
drown immediately? >> Please don't get a Frenchie. I just
wrote a Fox article talking about how problematic they are. Like
I don't give a [__] I know they have breathing problems.
I know they're incredibly bred. I don't give a [__]
That's what I know. We take >> He's like, I don't care
about imm people. I have lots of Jewish friends.
>> Yeah, that's what he thinks about. >> Chill out.
I mean, from his own mouth.
>> Okay. I just I I probably can't anymore. I I tried for
as long as we could. This guy's This guy's just a joker. Okay.
He's not even really like
I I don't know. This dude, a lot of people falling off. A lot
of internet's in flux right now. I don't know where people are
going. I don't know what people are watching. I have a hard time
like wa I watched 53 Minutes, but I I have a hard time watching
this, man. >> I know. I don't care. >> Is it possible
that he's saying he will love the dog regardless? >> No,
because he's he's expressing annoyance at the chatter like, "Oh,
how Oh, you're judging me. Oh, you idiot, loser. It's a dog.
Who cares? It's
>> you know." >> Why does he keep making this about
Israel? I don't know. I don't know, man.
kind of
this kind of it doesn't really hold water cuz you know the one
thing people right
are we categorically proving Hassan is not like once and for
all
in Ethan's mind
>> that's the way I heard it oh I'm supposed to rinse out
my mouth I'm going to do that >> just such a lib ass like
oh dude please don't get a Frenchie I just wrote a [__]
article talking about how problematic they are like I don't give
a I know they have breathing problems I know they're >> that
is what they say about actually yes that's true
uh guys Three subs away from another hour. Another two hour.
We have 55 seconds. Okay. I'll let you guys get in under the
wire if you want. Otherwise, uh you're on my time after that
and do whatever I want to do. >> Incredibly bread. I don't
give a [__] I know. I know. I don't care. Like I
don't give a [__] >> He's a dog. Just such
a >> Yeah, I don't see any way to spin that one. I don't
care. He goes, I don't care.
And because I'm honest, by the way, and I Three of my dogs are
rescued. One of them is bought. He's a purebred Yorkie I got
from a a trainer. a a breeder. I'm honest. I admit that. And
while I admit that there are
um challenges with buying purebred dogs, there are extremely
ethical ways to do it. And my solution that I say and I donated
I donate to pet shelters when I buy these dogs. I believe the
city of Los Angeles instead of being super auster and shutting
down dog breeders
>> private hub. Thank you for the gifted sub. Uh we are
also like I think we're $10 away if you guys want to get >> are
creating beautiful wonderful dogs that make are going to wonderful
homes. the people who want to buy designer dogs who have the
money to do that because you put a heavy tax on them that goes
direct what that's like the most win-win situation ever
people who want to buy these dogs are going to buy them >> right
it doesn't matter if you outlaw in the whole state which I believe
it >> I bought my dog the previous one we had a beagle
he was adopted but we have a golden doodle buddy now and my kids
were >> uh grle it's okay I um
no it's it's totally fine people don't have to donate if they
don't want to I have lots of stuff to do. >> Dead zone.
And that's what >> I've got. Uh we could go watch I'm I'm
just excited cuz we get to go watch that other Africa like the
actual Africa like geography thing that I was watching before.
I just get to share that with
>> But we found a guy in San Diego and for from day one
and made us buy this frozen dog food. We had to show proof of
purchase before we could even pick up the dog and he was dedicated
to >> raising healthy. >> Yeah. So, I mean the best
thing would be like because there are unethical uh dog breeders,
but
regulate it, tax it, right?
Why why run from it? Why hide from it? Um and then you have Hassan
who just lies about it, you know? >> Lib like, "Oh, dude."
>> Um Hassan's dog yelps, "Oh, we just That's the original
one." Hassan says he doesn't care. I saw that one.
Now, when we look at a close-up, right, people started to analyze
the close-up. And again, because Hassan immediate claim was,
"Oh, wait. She she uh must have pulled she must have fallen down
the stairs. She pulled her ankle. She she her toe got caught
on something. >> She ran into the wall. >> So, I
mean, we've looked at it. Here's the flash. Here's the caller.
We know it's an electric color.
Um here's a better look at the brand that it might be. People
found the exact brand on Amazon. >> Ethan is getting some
actual analysis here. Let's go. >> It has the bright yellow
part. >> That is not the brand. He's got some very outdated
info here. Now he actually totally this up like completely this
up entirely this up. And this is by the way seven hours ago
like he had all this all the actual information was out. So once
again Ethan shows up to a show. Listen as somebody who shows
up in my opinion unprepared sometimes. This is embarrassing.
Okay.
And he's got significantly more money, significantly more to
invest in to make sure he doesn't show up and look like a
very sad. Um,
it's similar.
This light seems to be down a little bit, but I think there's
actually Yeah, this one's irrelevant. I think better look at
the brand. >> Oh, so people have have triangulated the
exact brand. That was the the first iteration. Let me see. Um,
>> oh, here we go. >> It's just a caller, he says
before muting the mic and appearing
>> um to to appear to sneakily hand something off to his
mom.
So, here's another clip of his of him saying something about
the caller and then muting it for some reason, right? Muting
it to hide what he says and handing something to his mom. Take
a look at this. Another recent one. >> Yeah, it's just
a caller. >> It's just a caller. What do you mean? Why
would you even have to say that? >> It's just a caller.
>> Huh? Then why would you just say that? Why would When
have you ever clip? I didn't see this one before. >> This
looks like a shock collar.
>> Just a caller. >> Is it literally shock? Um, it
depends on what you mean. I think it has like leads that it uses
to to stimulate. Okay.
Does it shock in like a little like cattle prods? No, probably
not. He mutes >> Yeah, you use a caller. Uh,
>> hold on.
>> Mute it.
Now he's talking to his mom. Why mute it? What are you hiding?
You Who cares what you're talking to your mom about? He does
that all the time. He talks to his mom
>> without muting it. Yeah. Okay. I do app
>> That necklace looks stupid though. >> Yeah, he's
not. He's the phoniest. Hey, you're you're a real hype beast,
man. >> I don't know about that. >> Um, let's see.
>> But the puka necklace has got to go. >> Of course,
that Nissa, >> we got chatter saying that hurts. Um, I
mean, is any chatter put on the one that Lykan literally demonstrated
for us?
Like literally put one on and shocked himself multiple times
with it.
>> The dog expert immediately chimes in. shout out.
as this story breaks, as it's developing and it does not look
good for Hassan, throw her body on to to sacrifice herself to
Hassan. >> So unselfish. >> She goes, "And guys,
in addition to being a um doing a with Mia Khalifa, being a kinesiologist,
to being a um uh I don't know all of her tall tales, she's also
a huge dog advocate." Okay. She loves training dogs with positive
Hold on. >> To being a um doing a with Mia Khalifa, being
a kinesiologist
to being
>> I Yeah, I just I I'm glad that was top of mind for him.
That was That was just top of mind right there.
Oh, Ana came up.
Nissa, I want to Isa every single every single time he ever brings
her up. It's weird. Being a um uh I don't know all of her tall
tales. She's also a huge dog advocate.
Okay. She loves training dogs with positive enforcement as you
can tell with Merlin and Fiona on Ian's stream. Now, guys, she's
actually met Kaia one time when she was briefly at his house.
I saw Ka while Hassan was streaming. She never had a shot caller
on. Wow.
Wow. Yeah, I know. I don't And I don't assume people abuse their
kids in front of their house guests either. >> No. Do you
think he takes a shot collar off when he has like guests over?
>> Obviously. Obviously.
Of course you would. Um, she never had a shell collar. Wow, she
was so good at her place command. Yeah, she's obviously extremely
obedient, but that's very easily accomplished with positive reinforcement.
I would be very, very surprised if this was actually Kai reacting
to a shot caller. I like that she's built in here
that if it's proven to be a shot caller, I'm going to be forced
to have to denounce him. And it's not looking good. But she's
still finding ways to defend him. As a huge dog advocate, she's
actually the president of the Dog Humane Society of >> LA
president. But then she's pivots for no reason. Just because
Ethan's a >> Do these people have to like I feel like in
their heads they have to go and say, "Oh, Ana is presenting herself
as like um the premier dog expert in the world." It's like I
think she's just like giving her opinion saying she like in her
experience
like how much you have to hate this woman to be like she's just
acting like she's like the president of the SPCA of America.
I no she's just typing on Twitter and you're getting you're just
seething about it for some reason. You can just ignore her.
By the way, look at what she look at the numbers she and Idubbbz
get when they stream. That's what most of the world does. Just
ignores them. Why can't you do the same? A horrible dog owner.
What the did I do? I haven't even commented at this point, I
don't think. Just because Ethan's a horrible dog owner and can't
train his dogs where doesn't mean other people are using a shot
collar. Okay. Um, great. I My dog's training has another pathetic
attempt at deflection I have ever seen. >> I kind of like
the fact you got trapnel just from >> Well, of course I
catch shots.
>> And accuse the accusers of doing the same thing. No,
no, no. It wasn't a shot caller. Yeah. Actually, Ethan's a bad
dog owner. Huh?
The dogs love routine and training. If you can't train one, don't
get four again. What the [__] did I do? I'm so sorry
for taking three rescues in. What >> You know, you're right.
They should have been euthanized.
You Anissa would have been better would have been happier if
my three rescues would have been
>> Who who are terribly miserable. Who, by the way,
enjoy. Um, well, they they can they can get up, you know,
>> You know, >> no shot callers. >> Wow. These
guys are awesome.
Okay. Um All right. I I swear I can't anymore with Ethan. I'd
honestly rather watch Britney Simon. I find Britney Simon far
more compelling
as somebody to listen to.
Like I think I think Britney Simon at least has like some idea
of what's going on.
I don't know. I I would just I would rather watch Britney Simon.
I I'm not going to watch more right now, okay? But I just got
no interest in watching more of Ethan right now. I I tried I
tried to make it work.
It's a lot. Okay. It's a lot to watch this guy.
All right. Okay. With the liking video, I'm going to pull up
my
the video I wanted to do and then I we'll see. We'll see what
we do tonight. I think I'm just going to pull up
this bad boy. Give me a second. Where's my My documents gone.
Hold on. Hold on.